metropolitan police the the statement
they said was the most serious and
flagrant allegations of um
of what went on that's why they were
investigating those in terms of what we
might get today what kind of picture
will it give us and why then in that
sense does the zoo grey report still
matter
well i think what matters really is not
necessarily what she says but what the
reaction is to it from conservative mps
we know that
two weeks ago there was an attempted
uh an attempt to force boris johnson
from office and attempt to get those 54
tory mps
in 1920 i was talking to one of those
tory rebels this morning who told me
that really the atmosphere is totally
changed in the party now but there's not
really so much of an appetite for
getting rid of boris johnson could there
be something in the report this
afternoon which reignites that and means
that we're having those same discussions
again this afternoon to be honest it
seems quite unlikely but it could be
that there's a new detail in there that
uh that really angered story mps and
suddenly we start having those slightly
more existential questions from the pm
again
until you go in and out of westminster
and this whole political sphere every
day what's the sense that you're getting
is the sense that the longer this drags
on just as we've had the drip drip drip
of party allegations we get getting a
drip drip drip of report metropolitan
policing investigation more sugray
report is the sting coming out of the
tail for the prime minister is this good
for him the longer this drags on i think
at this point the story becomes about a
series of reports doesn't it i mean
early on this story was about having
another party and more explosive
allegations you know these ideas of
people having big celebrations during
lockdown i mean that was something that
was really making the public angry this
is now about when's a certain report
going to come out will it be delayed how
much is it going to be redacted it's
become a story which feels kind of
important but a bit more boring now and
i think if boris johnson can prolong the
full findings of this inquiry until
after the metropolitan police
investigation which will probably take
quite a while it could be that the
public's kind of forgotten about all
these stories by then and that for him
feels a lot less dangerous
behind the headlines if you like
why are people coming out with these
photos and details of parties now are
these disgruntled staff members are they
people perhaps who have
left the
government why do people want to talk
about
these parties now why are they coming
forward well obviously we can't talk
about the sources i'm just trying to get
a sense of where they come from because
people have been really interested in
terms of you know some of this happened
nearly two years ago now yeah i mean i
think
from what we've been told from talking
to people who were involved it did feel
to a lot of these people like what was
going on at the time wasn't really that
wrong that there was kind of a bubble in
westminster and particularly in downing
street people while others were working
from home all the time these people were
coming in and out of work every day they
were seeing their colleagues they were
having a glass of wine in the evening
perhaps as extraordinary as it might
feel to us perhaps it was that these
people didn't really expect that what
they were doing at the time would cause
such a big problem and you know once you
get one of these stories you realize how
politically sensitive uh they are and
then either people who come forward
because they think the truth should be
out there or because they've got a
they've got a bone to pick or just
because they're asked and they say oh
yes actually that was going on um these
things start to come out but you're
right it does feel slightly odd to us
that these people didn't really know
that at the time
at the time when you know those who were
living through would have immediately
spotted somebody perhaps and just in
terms of i know you have to go the
secret report is imminent just a final
question
what do you see happening after this
report comes out do you think it's going
to be a bit of a damp squib or do you
think we will really find out something
of substance today it looks like we
probably won't get any major new details
as frustrating as that is for us as
journalists to watch i think we probably
won't get anything too significant um
we'll probably see an attempt by some
conservative mps to use this to force
restaurants from office we might see a
bit more anonymous source quotes from
those mps talking about it whether or
not it will actually happen i think
we'll probably be waiting for the
outcome of the police inquiry before
that happens
too long to wait for part one of bridge
sue grey light whatever we want to call
it it's on its way in a few minutes time
tony really good to see you thank you
for coming to danny street to see us a
tony driver their political
correspondent at the telegraph
um well boris johnson has repeatedly
denied that rules were broken here in
downing street during lockdown
all guidance was followed all the
guidelines were observed continue to be
observed those were people at work those
were meetings of people at work talking
about this is where i live and to where
i work those were meetings of people at
work talking about work i apologize
for
uh for the impression that uh has been
given uh that staff and danny street
take this less than seriously uh i'm i
i'm sickened myself and furious about
that the evidence i can see is that uh
people in this building have stayed
within the rules if that turns out not
to be the case
and and people wish to bring uh
allegations to uh to my attention or to
the to the police or whoever then of
course uh there will be a proper
sanctions
are you watching sky news live from
downing street i have just been warned
by our political editor beth rigby that
the prime minister is about to come out
of downing street and she will shout a
question at him so beth don't you worry
i'm on standby for you to leave me and
shout question the prime minister but
this is a big moment for him he's seen
the report we are moments away from
seeing the the update sugree has given
downing street um a really really big
day for the premise
his chief whip went in slightly earlier
that will be because his chief whip mark
spence will be briefing him about the
statement to the comments they got this
report at about 11 20. there is some
anger i should say that it still hasn't
been released by some of his
backbenchers we're expecting it
literally any minute now we'll be seeing
at the same time as we will yeah it will
be laid in parliament we will all see it
will go on the government websites but
some anger that they've had it now for
three hours he's been able to make his
preparations
his parliamentary party and the public
still haven't seen it nor have the
opposition he will address mps all of
his party tonight uh one uh source in
the party said to me that they partly
thought he might be bringing along uh
the payroll so ministers uh aids
paid on the government books to make him
have more support
in the room someone said he probably
doesn't want to face the back benches
and some of those that have publicly
called for his resignation without some
of his reinforcements but it all tallies
with the idea that this is a pm trying
to display a show of strength as he's
been doing
for the past few days as for the details
of the report what is clear is that a
lot of it will not be in there so much
of the most egregious potential breaches
are now being investigated by the met
they decided last week it was serious
enough what sugray had uncovered that
they wanted to conduct their own
investigations people in number 10 could
be facing fixed penalty notices
for breaching the rules it could be that
the prime minister is either interviewed
as a witness or under caution but the
big question is what did he know and
when and mps will want to see
whether lockdown rules were breached and
some of that detail but the big question
is how much will we know now and how
decisive will that be in mp's form in
their view about boris johnson and his
premiership yeah you do get the sense
that if there is any evidence that rules
laws were broken that would be under the
remit of the metropolitan police
investigation sue gray's report as we
understand it today will not cover
any of those gatherings but perhaps some
of the smaller gatherings that you know
the police don't feel
did break the rules in that sense
what do you think we'll get today in
terms of will it change anything or are
we more likely to hear the prime
minister to say you're going to have to
wait for the results of the police
investigation now there's another
holding pattern
when after
after the met last tuesday announced it
was investigating
the general view around here was that
that was a relief for the prime minister
because it kicked the can
down the road now you're in a kind of
curious situation when a prime minister
and his team have been investigated uh
by the police for rules that they've
reached but nevertheless it was thought
it would give him some breathing space
then there's some movement outside
number 10 i think the pm is coming out
because i can see one of his aides uh
coming out i think he'll be coming out
imminently
where was i sorry yeah so the mets
the met announcing that investigation
meant that because they then asked sue
gray on sunday to only have minimal
reference in her report
to events that they were investigating
it meant that much of that report was
filleted that is why today she said she
was providing an update this is not
a full disclosure of events and the big
question is and i'm sure the prime
minister will be asked in the commons
whether he will once the investigation
has concluded
publish all of this so the public get
the full picture about what happened in
number 10 over a series of months and
and two lockdowns we talked about
momentum didn't we earlier beth about
the fact that last week you really felt
there was momentum in terms of back
bench mps
those mps who broke through the red wall
um
really sort of
banding together to voice their
discomfort with the prime minister
perhaps you know working towards this
vote of no confidence do you think the
sting has gone out of the tail in this
in terms of the longer we wait look
there's there's a kind of there's two
questions here there's kind of
short-term boris johnson political
survival i think there is a mood now uh
that his short-term political survival
is more assured some heat taken out of
that rolling sense of things out of his
control and falling apart around him
there is then a longer question which
the conservative party will have to
consider which is do they think that
boris johnson is the right man to lead
them into the next general election
and yes there has been a move to support
him and shore him up a big whipping
operation going on grant schatz the
transport secretary who helped with his
leadership bid has got his spreadsheet
out and they're going through the mps
and he's going around to see them but
there is a lot of disquiet on the
benches 2019ers who are worried that
they will lose their seats because of
this in marginal constituents they think
that the pm and their constituents are
now
irreconcilable and then there's also the
one nation tories up to 50 of them
unhappy as well i'm just going to
interrupt you we're waiting for the
prime minister but deputy political sam
coats in our westminster studio has eyes
on the sugray report
yeah it is a short report it's about 12
uh pages long uh and it just sets out at
the beginning uh the various things that
uh uh protesters that sue grey was asked
it talks about how an investigation was
launched on the 8th of december
into what happened in whitehall during
the pandemic and in the department for
education how sue gray took over on the
17th of december
and how she was given a
terms of reference uh to look at a whole
series of different events inside number
ten uh this report which we're looking
at for the first time as you as you can
see on your screen um essentially
uh looks at uh uh looks at uh all of the
um uh all of the different events uh
that she's uh uh was asked and tasked
with looking what and uh we're gonna go
straight to page seven uh which looks at
her general findings so looking at these
uh for the first time together against
the backdrop of the pandemic when the
government was asking citizens to accept
far-reaching restrictions on their lives
some of the behavior surrounding these
gatherings is difficult to justify at
least some of the gatherings in question
represent a serious failure to observe
not just the high standards expected of
those working at the heart of government
but also of the standards expected of
the entire british population at the
time at times it seems there was too
little thought given to what was
happening across the country in
considering the appropriateness of some
of these gatherings the risks that they
presented to public health and how they
might appear to the public there were
failures of leadership and judgment by
different parts of number 10 and the
cabinet office at different times some
of the events should not have been
allowed to take place other events
should not have been allowed to develop
as they did
the excessive consumption of alcohol is
not appropriate in a professional
workplace at any time steps must be
taken to ensure that every government
department has a clear and robust policy
in place covering the consumption of
alcohol in the workplace
now she goes on to talk about specific
and more general findings related to
certain events the use of the garden at
number 10 downing street should be
primarily for the prime minister and the
private residence of number 10 and
number 11 downing street during the
pandemic it was often used as an
extension of the workplace as it was a
covered secure means of holding group
meetings in a ventilated space this was
a sensible measure that staff
appreciated but the garden was also used
for gatherings without clear
authorization or oversight this was not
appropriate any official access to the
space including for meetings should be
by invitation only and in a controlled
environment some staff wanted to raise
concerns about behaviors they witnessed
at work but at times felt unable to do
so no member of staff should feel unable
to report or challenge poor conduct when
they witness it there should be easier
ways
for staff to raise such concerns
individually
informally outside of the line
management chain the number of staff
working in number 10 downing street has
steadily increased in recent years and
in terms of size scale and range of
responsibilities it's now more akin to a
government department uh and she talks
about structure but then we go on to the
conclusions
the gatherings within the scope of this
investigation are spread over a 20-month
period a period that has been unique in
recent times in terms of the complexity
and breadth of the demands on public
service servant and indeed the general
public the whole of the country rose to
the challenge ministers special advisers
and the civil service of which i am
proud to be a part were a key and
dedicated part of that national effort
however as i have noted a number of
these gatherings should not have been
allowed to take place or to develop in
the way that they did there is
significant learning to be drawn from
these events which must be addressed
immediately across government this does
not need to wait for the police
investigation to be concluded so there
you have the key bits of the sugree
report i just want to go back to one
absolutely critical uh paragraph where
she talks about failures of leadership
and judgment by different bits of number
10 and the cabinet office i think that
is going to be quite a challenge for the
prime minister today
um sam thank you very much indeed i'm in
downing street waiting for the prime
minister to leave number 10 to the house
of commons he's addressing the comments
at 3 30 this afternoon he'll be on his
way shortly our political editor beth
rigby uh is here alongside me and beth
you've just been going through that
report as um our viewers saw sam take us
through the keem findings um and again
he did reference that paragraph where it
talked about the failures of leadership
and another interesting bit where they
said um too much responsibility and
expectation is placed on the senior
official whose principle function is the
direct support of the prime minister
this should be addressed as a matter of
priority anything related to the prime
minister personally in that report well
i think that is the key question but in
terms of what sue gray is saying she's
quite clear here in conclusion she says
a number of these gatherings should not
have been allowed to take place or to
develop in the way that did she also
references that senior official is that
martin reynolds the prime minister's
principal private secretary
and the pressure that he has been
publicly under over sending that email
the prime minister insisting on that may
20th gathering that he was not aware in
advance of it even though dominic
cummings one of his advisers at the time
has gone on the record saying he
personally uh warned him and then this
at least some of the gatherings in
question represent a serious failure to
observe not just the high standards
expected of those working at the heart
of government but also of the standards
expected of the entire british
population
at the time and then uh in terms of uh
what the view is uh from the opposition
i think that
they're alerting to me to a key line on
page five it is not possible at present
to provide a meaningful report and i
think that that is one of the questions
today that this report
is clearly critical of number 10 but it
is only a partial picture but it does
beg the question that if sue gray is
clearly talking publicly about serious
failures then surely the prime minister
will be under huge pressure now to
actually release
all of the evidence and give the british
people a full picture of what really was
going on in number 10. yeah there were
failures of leadership and judgement by
different parts of number 10 and the
cabinet office at different times
how damaging is this for the prime
minister in its current form beth we
were talking about it being an update
and as you said this is not the full
report
if you were his sort of crisis
communications manager as such what
would you be saying to the prime
minister well this is bad news this is
sue gray is clearly critical she says at
least some of the gatherings in question
represent a serious failure to observe
not just the high standards of those
expected at the heart
of government a serious failure that are
they you know they will be the standout
words uh and the prime minister is now
going to have to go to parliament and
explain uh all of this away but as i
said he has been given a reprieve if you
like in the fact that the mets are
investigating some of those serious
breaches because it means that the full
picture can't emerge today and if it had
emerged how much deeper would be the
trouble that he's in over this yeah and
i think
in this um a bridge version of sugray's
report it does reflect uh what a lot of
people have been telling us here at sky
news those who keep saying you know
partygate does matter because we lost
loved ones we couldn't go to loved ones
funerals we missed the births of our
sons and daughters
it says in the general findings against
the backdrop of the pandemic when the
government was asking citizens to accept
far-reaching
restrictions on their lives some of the
behaviour surrounding these gatherings
is difficult to justify and that's what
a lot of the public reaction has been
about there yeah i mean i'm just having
a look at some of the other bits the
report again a number of these
gatherings should not have been allowed
to take place she looked at 16 events
over 12 separate dates she interviewed
70
people and she has concluded
that a number of the gatherings should
not have taken place now there are
obvious consequences for that people are
going to be have to help have to be held
accountable but ultimately the prime
minister went into the house of commons
in december and said no rules had been
broken he told parliament that and now
sue grey is clearly saying that
gathering should not have taken place
and draw from that what you will okay
beth thank you we're going to go back to
our westminster studio and our deputy
political editor sam coats who has been
having another look through this report
and picking things out but you know sam
so many lines that jump out there
particularly to people watching at home
who had to make sacrifices during the
lockdown see gray saying you know
the behavior surrounding these
gatherings is difficult to justify
that's what she says it's up to the
metropolitan police of course and their
investigation uh to decide whether
people actually broke the law
absolutely and i think what's really
interesting as we go through this
admittedly fairly limited just 12-page
report with uh appendices and
methodologies so the core uh the core of
this document is very short indeed is
that there is a bit in light so i've
actually put it in yellow here
where sue grey basically says i just
can't tell you i just can't tell you
very much of what i would want to let me
read this paragraph paragraph 14 as a
result of the metropolitan police's
investigations and so as not to
prejudice the police investigative
process they have told me that it would
only be appropriate to make minimal
reference to the gatherings on the dates
that they're investigating and here's
the key bit unfortunately this
necessarily means that i am extremely
limited in what i can say about these
events and it is not possible to present
at present to provide a meaningful
report setting out and analyzing the
extensive factual information i have
been able to gather now that's sue grey
telling us i've got lots of things that
you might want to know but i can't tell
you today
she goes into a bit more of what that
means in the paragraph ahead she said
that she has provided the material to
the police to help them in their
investigation and she has retained all
the other information collected
but she says essentially she's going to
lock it in a safe i will therefore
ensure the secure storage and
safekeeping of all the information
gathered until such time as it may be
required further she is putting in light
her desire uh in this section here
uh she's putting in lights uh in her uh
in
her here uh essentially the idea that
she wants to be able uh potentially to
have the right to the right to release
more of it i will not be circulating the
information internally within government
as it has been provided in confidence to
the cabin office investigation team and
it is important that this confidence is
maintained to protect the integrity of
the process so that is three things she
has more information she isn't gonna
disclose it yet but she's happy to
potentially in the future and she's not
going to share it with boris johnson yet
fascinating stuff that sets up for a
fight ahead whether or not boris johnson
will allow a publication of the full fat
sugree report sugray 2.0 back here with
a longer report with the whole narrative
of what really went on once the police
have finished their work sarah jane
sam thank you our deputy political
editor there going through the report in
the studio for us we're live in downing
street we're waiting for the prime
minister to walk out of that number 10
door into the waiting car to head to the
house of commons he is making a
statement at 3 30 this
afternoon um while we wait for prime
minister to leave number 10 let's speak
to human rights barrister adam wagner
he'll be uh familiar to many of you he's
been
very vocal and
brilliant quite frankly in keeping us up
to date with the covered rules because
they were confusing to so many people uh
during the lockdown but he knows what's
what and he's been quite a vocal in
putting them into perspective for people
particularly in lights of parties and
gatherings at downing street adam good
afternoon to you
good afternoon um you've had a look at
this report only 12 pages long but um
what everybody was saying before it came
out is it's going to be interesting to
see what is not included in this report
because the parties that aren't
will be in the hands of the metropolitan
police and just quickly looking through
this report one two three four and sue
gray's report only mentions four parties
when when you think there are 16 17
under investigation that's a lot for the
met police to look at
well sue gray was asked to look at 16
and she says the metropolitan police are
now looking at all of those gatherings
except for four
and that's i think actually that is the
most important bit of new information
that's in this report because previously
we had been um led to understood there
was something like eight but crucially
in terms of the prime minister that
includes the the the gatherings that the
police are looking at includes his
birthday party gathering in june 2020
um the and the party in the or the
gathering in the garden
in may 2020 they bring your own booze uh
gathering
so that is a really important bit of
information that we didn't know
yeah adam you've been talking on sky
news about um what the coveted rules
were at the time of the prime minister's
birthday gathering if people need
reminding what gathering that was that
was the one with cake and the singing of
happy birthday as you understand it
reminded us of the rules at that time in
context of what we understand may have
happened in the prime minister's office
um well at the time gatherings of more
than one person um for without
unless they fell within a specific
exception
were illegal so no social gatherings
were permitted they had to be
reasonably necessary for work
um and
it's difficult to see how as i've said
all along
a gathering that was specifically for
celebration of a birthday with food and
drink or whatever there was
would be within the rules i mean i think
it probably wasn't and i think that's
why don't forget the police have applied
a very high threshold as to what they're
investigating they say that has that
they have to be egregious breaches of
the rules and also no real ambiguity
over a reasonable excuse so it's very
telling
what they have been what they have
decided to investigate
and it tells us something about what's
going to happen potentially next
yeah i mean that's just one example um
as you said all but four examples of
some 16 to 17
alleged gatherings or parties have been
handed over to the police and you know
just your description of that one
example
that maybe
how the police are viewing those other
examples that they're looking at as well
in terms of the report itself and how
it's worded it is lacking in detail
but overall the tone and what sue gray
has written what's your assessment of
that in how damaging it is to the prime
minister
well i mean it's totally scathing it's
um there's no
there's no uh mercy here for the for the
civil servants or for the prime minister
essentially what she's saying is
we were held to very high standards and
we did not meet them that's essentially
what i read from this report she talks
about failures of leadership and
judgment excessive consumption of
alcohol at least some of the gatherings
being a serious failure failure not to
observe not just the high standards
expected of those working at the heart
of government but also the standards
expected of the entire british
population at the time
um and and there's no doubt
that the um that what the that you don't
really need to read between the lines
that she has herself
probably come to the conclusion that a
significant number of these um
gatherings breach the guidelines and
potentially breach the law that's why
it's been passed over to the
metropolitan police so in terms of how
it paints the picture
it's it it's it's given it's not the
full report it's just effectively an
interim
um set of findings um trying to uh
negotiate between this difficult
position and having to inform the public
and also
um satisfy the police
it's it is damning it really is damning
and this is only the update it isn't the
full report adam wagner as always really
good to talk to you about the situation
here on sky news thank you very much
some of the
behavior surrounding these gatherings
difficult to justify says sue gray in
this update some of the gatherings
represent a serious failure to observe
the high standards of office at times it
seems too little thought was given to
what was happening across the country
let's get more on the report it was only
12 pages but our deputy political editor
sam coats has been taking a look to what
little information is in there it might
be a little sam but it does say a lot
it does and in fairly damning terms as
well adam wagner uh talking to you just
a moment absolutely a moment ago
absolutely right that sue gray has not
pulled her punches with what she can say
whilst making clear that there's an
awful lot that she can't one of the
things that she says at the start of the
report is she really can't go into much
detail because of that metropolitan
police inquiry a little bit later she
reveals that there are only four of the
16 events that she can really go into
any detail about at all that aren't
being investigated uh by the police but
there's one eye-catching event uh that
uh i have certainly come across in the
last few moments now you might remember
on the 13th of november 2020 uh where
you were for the moment that dominic
cummings left downing street carrying a
box of his possessions well here we are
it looks as if one of the things that
sue gray has been investigating is a
gathering not just in number 10 but in
the number 10 flat the private residence
of boris johnson and carrie johnson
now there have long been rumors some of
it put about by dominic cummings himself
that boris johnson
oh carrie johnson had some kind of party
to celebrate uh the end of dominic
cummings uh because there was an interc9
battle in the heart of number 10 around
that period uh with uh
one faction many of them allies of the
prime minister's wife trying to get rid
of dominic cummings on that day he
finally went and it appears that sue
gray is now identifying a gathering in
the number 10 flat that she previously
uh that carrie johnson and boris johnson
live in now previously we had not
necessarily anticipated that sue gray's
report would include an investigation
into what happened in that flat uh above
downing street where they live because
it's their private residence so it's
quite striking not only uh that it's in
the list here that boris that sue gray
has um published uh of the things that
she has had to investigate but also it's
not one of those on the list where the
metropolitan police have already ruled
out there being any cause for further
investigation uh for that so that line
in itself in of itself could be pretty
uh critical and pretty painful uh if sue
gray decides and the metropolitan police
decides in particular that there's uh
potentially
something that warrants further action
um sam thank you sam coats who's been
taking a look through sue grey's update
in the westminster studio for us thank
you very much now
on the 19th of june 2020 while boris
johnson was partying in downing street
donna levermore was housebound she was
caring for her daughter who is
recovering from a thyroid cancer
operation and donna joins me now because
donna like so many people up and down
the country you have been taking
partygate at its as it's called
personally um i just want to read to you
some of sugray's report that may
resonate with you it says against the
backdrop of the pandemic when the
government was asking citizens to accept
far-reaching restrictions on their lives
some of the behavior surrounding these
gatherings is difficult to justify at
least some of the gatherings in question
represent a serious failure to observe
not just the high standards expected of
those working at the heart of government
but also the standards expected of the
entire british population at the time
tell me how you're feeling donna after
hearing that
yeah i think i i feel vindicated to be
honest um
you know he his whole caricature boris
you know is one of playing up his
ineptitude you know and now we're
actually finally um through due
diligence from sugray
seeing that
in fact this is actually a very cruel
person and his cohorts around him have
knowingly and consciously done these
things
you know and there's just no
there's no getting away from it there's
nowhere for him to hide
and as much as liz trust
says that you know
putin's got nowhere to hide well i'm
afraid byros has got nowhere to hide
he's tried many places now he really
does not have anywhere to hide
um sue gray
says also in the report there were
failures of leadership and judgment by
different parts of number 10 and the
cabinet office
at different times so it's not just the
prime minister who's at fort here but
those who work around him but from your
point of view
is it boris johnson
that carries the can for this 100 yes
100 but of course the cohort must go
with him
because it is endemic
you know be people behave in that way
because they're either encouraged or
allowed
um you know so they don't just go off
and do whatever they feel like doing
it's allowed it's encouraged so you know
he has to take the full responsibility
but the psycho fans around him have to
go
donna i want to allow you the time to
remind people what you were doing on
your birthday in the pandemic when the
prime minister was having cake
and have having happy birthday sung to
him at different gatherings they talk
about the excessive consumption of
alcohol sue grey's phrase there remind
us what you were doing while all this
was going on behind me
like many people
i was in a situation where my daughter
had had her operation cancelled
quite a few times because of the numbers
in of covert patients fill in the wards
and we had been backwards and forwards
across country
to to arrive for the operation to happen
when it finally did and we literally had
to get back in in a private taxi for
four hours and come back down to where
we were living at the time in winchester
and um from that second on i was on my
own with my daughter and you know
nursing her through
a really traumatic situation like many
other people and it was the trauma that
surrounded all of this that i think hurt
the most you know that whilst they were
doing what they were doing everybody
else was traumatized to one degree or
another and we were in a terrible
terrible position and we just had to
just be serious and
be strong
and we had no contact no physical
contact at all with anyone and it was
heartbreaking absolutely heartbreaking
you know couldn't even hug my daughter
because she was recovering in so much
pain and and i needed a hug i couldn't
have one you know and there was no one
to allow me to you know go and have a
drink on my birthday or anything else
celebrate and i just find it
just one of the most sickening things
that i think i'll never ever ever forget
no matter what comes of this
donna the prime minister is addressing
the house of commons at 3 30 this
afternoon what do you want to hear from
him
it'll be lovely if we could actually get
him to to say thank you very much i'm
really sorry and and
i'm out of here
and give the met
the
time and reprieve for the government
then to
to reform but he's not going to do that
is he
um you know it'll be yet another
um written pre-written pre-recorded
speech that he loves making um of
another duck and dive
and
i'd love to be able to say to him
seriously you know
how can you look at yourself in the
mirror how can you how can you stand
here in front of us
you know i really would
well donna um we know it's difficult for
you to talk about this we really
appreciate you coming on to sky news to
talk on behalf of your family and others
up and down the country that will have
gone through situations similar to yours
during the national lockdowns we really
appreciate your time this afternoon
thank you so much
donna levermore there who shares a
birthday with the prime minister but
we're celebrating very differently
during the lockdown
let's head to dudley up in the west
midlands uh sky's becky johnson is there
she's been engaging the public mood now
that the report in part is out becky
very little information but what is
there is pretty damning
it is and people were watching uh
ourselves on sky news actually as this
detail's been coming out forming their
own views of course it's been a topic of
conversation and it matters places like
here in dudley this is one of those
so-called red wall seats that went blue
last time and it's the opinions of
people here and in seats like this that
really matter now let's have a chat to
some people um i'll speak to dan first
because dan told me you voted
conservative for the first time in your
whole life last time what do you make of
boris johnson his parties this report
saying there were failures of leadership
and judgment well without saying any
swear words
he's a bad man
he is and
i wouldn't vote for conservative ever
again
and i'm 74 years of age and i've never
voted conservative in my life until the
last time
and
what is it about what's gone on that's
upset you so much well it's the promises
we were given especially old age
pensioners and they haven't followed
them up
and it's as simple as that and the
parties they've had and there's people
been dying
and they haven't their parents and
you know their those sons and daughters
haven't been able to see them and he's
having parties at number 10.
would you vote conservative again no
never again
other people some of yourselves how do
you feel about it
i think he's doing a good job
yeah and a lot of people saying that
actually
they don't care
brexit
pandemic
he's done well so do you care what's in
this report that's been published by
secretary i don't know what the report
is
couldn't tell
all right thank you very much for
talking to us well we can uh go over now
and speak to
becky uh becky you lost your mum during
the pandemic what what do you make of
this report saying that these events
shouldn't have been allowed to go on so
i do do as i say but not what i do
really isn't it so he's just doing what
he wants to do and he just
doesn't care
about any of us
i'd never vote for him ever
no he doesn't support the
british people at all
we've heard some people some people in
this pub here saying to us that actually
you know we've been talking about this
for a long time actually they don't
really care actually some people telling
me that they themselves break the rules
do you think he's going to weather this
storm well we didn't write the rules we
we was really we never saw any family at
all did we probably monks and we really
did keep to the rules my mom kept the
rules all of her life like you know like
with the kobe she when she came up to
our house she just you know wouldn't
even go in the garden she'd stay two
meters apart and then he's having
parties it's just not right it's not
fair that he's involved
so we're going to hear from the prime
minister about half past three what do
you want to hear from him resign
definitely resign because he's not good
enough for the job i mean
i'm not sure about that kirsten i mean
he's probably better than him but i'll
just say boris just go because you're
just a joke
he's just a joke
he's just a big joke to me i'll never
vote for him i never voted i'm never
gonna vote for him all right thank you
very much for talking to us so yeah a
real mix of reactions uh i would say
about half the people we've spoken to
say look you know they don't really care
what the prime minister's up to they're
pleased with some of the other things
that he did like deliver brexit but
people like becky and people like dan
who you heard from saying that this has
really affected their view of this prime
minister and becky they're saying that
he needs to now resign uh given what she
went through and many others like her
losing her mum during this pandemic and
not being able to properly say goodbye
and now she knows what was going on in
downing street
uh becky johnson thank you becky johnson
gauging some public reaction there in
dudley this afternoon and the sioux
report sugreed report the update is out
joining me now from central lobby in the
houses of parliament is the leader of
the liberal democrats ed davis ed davey
i'm good of you to join us this
afternoon have you had a chance to have
a look at the report
yeah i've had been able to skim read it
and i think it's a damning indictment of
the prime minister uh even within the
very severe limitations imposed on sue
gray
her findings talk of a lack of
leadership of behavior that was
inappropriate not just at the highest
levels but from anyone
and i think
really the prime minister must go
and i'm calling today on conservative
mps to do their patriotic duty i think
it's the patriotic duty of conservative
mps to tell this prime minister he has
to go
uh if even in this update this uh
summary report uh his leadership is
found to have failed it's time he went
yeah the report there was only 12 pages
it has been described as an update but
what little there was said a lot um
parties definitely took place we know
that now and there was no evidence boris
johnson was advised they were unlawful
and there was no justification for them
sue grey very clear about that uh in her
summaries um
are we any clearer about the prime
minister's future looking at what you've
seen so far do we need the metropolitan
police report do we need more from sue
gray to know that he lied
i don't think we need any more we didn't
even need this update i think it's clear
as date to millions of people the prime
minister lied and he broke the rules and
even the limitations of uh this update
from sue gray it's pretty clear that she
thinks that too
the lack of leadership she talks about
well who's in charge of number 10 it's
the prime minister so it's his
leadership that's failed he's failed the
country and
tory mps must now stand up and be
counted the prime minister won't resign
as liberal democrats believe he should
it's time tory mp's called time to do
their patriotic duty and tell him to go
what do you think we will hear from the
prime minister at 3 30 today everybody
seems convinced that he won't resign and
sue gray hints that there is more to
come of course there is a full report no
update on whether that will be published
in full now that we've had the update
that may well change and she said it's
not possible at present to provide a
meaningful report setting out and
analyzing the extensive factual
information i have been able to gather
that's a massive hint there that this is
going to get worse for the prime
minister
i think you're right uh and as for today
uh i'm pretty sure the prime minister
will apologize and he'll do his pretend
apologies you know he's like he doesn't
really apologize he pretends to
apologize uh and i'm sure he won't go
that's why it's up to conservative mps
not to
leave the country in this limbo any
longer we've got serious matters to deal
with we've got the energy crisis the
cost of living crisis we've got ukraine
we've still got the pandemic these are
serious issues and because boris johnson
has lied and broken the rules
that his whole government is in limbo is
in paris polaris we need action and he
has to go and the conservative mps
should do that the times on twitter
how much will you be pushing for the
full sue gray report now because it may
be that um you know it's suggested that
that won't be published in full giving
how damning the update has been how much
will you push for that and hold the
prime minister to his promise that it
will be
well we also got to ask the metropolitan
police and particularly crested dick
if they it seems from what we've seen
from the update that
new scotland yard has said that various
parts can't be published
they need to give a full and detailed
explanation of why they can't be
published there are many experts out
there who think it should and could be
published without in any way getting
away
of the investigations i'm not an expert
but i'm happy to go with what these
experts have said it seems pretty clear
so the met police if it's not going to
be publishing for have got some
explaining to do
and
we heard from donna levermore earlier on
who shares her birthday with the prime
minister and was painting a picture of
what her birthday was like during the
national lockdown while the prime
minister had cake and had happy birthday
sung to him by colleagues she was
looking after her daughter who was
recovering from a serious operation she
couldn't even hug her daughter those
were the rules at the time she was
having a thoroughly miserable birthday
what will you say to people like donna
and other families up and down the
country about where this story goes next
because as you said the prime minister
is not going to resign it's in the hands
of conservative mps it all feels like a
political game to them and they don't
feel like any heads are gonna roll
well my heart goes out to donna i have
myself many constituents who've
contacted me and they've told me what
they were doing when the prime minister
was partying i've had two concessions
who told me that on the 20th of may one
of the more infamous parties they were
burying their fathers
and they taught tell me of their
distress how upset they were and frankly
how angry they are
so whether it's donor or microcesius or
millions like them i think if the prime
minister really won't resign if
conservative mps really won't do
their patriotic duty
parliament's got to have a vote of no
confidence in the government
we've got to find some way of holding
this scoundrel to account
what about those who say
look the prime minister on the big
decision has been getting things right
for the country i was in wolverhampton
last week and voters there were saying
to me in wolverhampton south west which
voted conservative in 2019
after being one from labour they were
saying look on the big decisions he's
kept our businesses here on the high
street afloat they weren't personally
affected like donna levermore were but
in the grand scheme of things they
didn't see partygate as that big a deal
what would you say to those voters
well on things like furlough
we had cross party support for those
liberal democrats were backing that
support for businesses but i think on
many of the other big decisions actually
the prime minister's got it very badly
wrong he didn't prepare the country for
the pandemic we locked down far too late
the care homes were not protected we've
had a death rate because of covid far
higher than most of the countries and
our economy has been worse hit than most
of the countries so actually i think by
and large the minister's got the prime
minister's come out the big questions
are wrong
and i think i would hold him to account
for those but i'd also hold him to
account for his failure to be running
the country properly now with the costs
living crisis and the way he's lied and
the way he's broken the rules so i think
there's a very long charge sheet against
the prime minister i think he's the
worst prime minister in british history
okay sir ed davey leader of the liberal
democrats thank you for your time here
on sky news this afternoon
it is three o'clock we are live here in
downing street this afternoon the sue
grey report has been released saying
that behavior during the national
lockdown at number 10 and in the offices
is difficult to justify she say cites
failures of leadership and some of the
events should not have been allowed i
will have more on this highly critical
abridged version of sue gray's findings
into parties at downing street coming up
shortly
[Music]
but in the meantime we're going to take
a closer look at some of the detail uh
conclusions that there were failures of
leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 and the cabinet
office at times it adds that some events
should not have been allowed to take
place others should not have developed
as they did it says that when the
government was asking citizens to accept
far-reaching restrictions on their lives
some of the behavior surrounding these
gatherings is difficult to justify
some staff wanted to raise concerns
about behaviors they witnessed at work
but at times they felt unable to do so
the report adds that gatherings
represented a serious failure to observe
the high standards expected of those
working at the heart of government
lack of thought was given in considering
the appropriateness of gatherings and
finally sue gray states that an
excessive consumption of alcohol is not
appropriate in a professional workplace
well we are expecting the prime minister
to leave a number 10 downing street any
moment now to head to the house of
commons he's giving that statement at 3
30 and our political editor beth rigby
is here alongside me and beth just 12
pages long
but pretty damning yeah i should say the
prime minister is going is going to come
out of number 10 at any moment now um
and i will shout if he does
in terms of where we are at this report
it's only 12
pages long but there are many many
questions for him to answer when he goes
to the house of commons number one grace
says
that some of the gatherings represent a
serious failure to observe standards
some of the events should not have been
allowed to take place failures of
leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 and the cabinet
office some staff wanted to raise
concerns but felt unable to do so but
also and i think this is quite critical
she also says it is not possible at
present to provide
a meaningful report and in this report
it's clear that there are 12
parties that the mets are now
investigating one of which was in the
downing street flat the one that dominic
cummings claimed happened on november
the 13th the night he left and she has
sue gray given a very very bare-bones
summary and update as the cabinet office
said and i think the fact that there is
no information in this report but lots
of misgivings about what was going on
number 10.
dan rosenfeld will you have to resign
that was the prime minister's chief of
staff the fact that
the fact that they have so many
investigations well you have to resign
prime minister is it a failure of
leadership prime minister failure of
leadership prime minister
there you go um boris johnson's just got
into the car
with dan rosenfeld who's his chief of
staff going to number 10 and of course
those questions about will you have to
resign expect that from the opposition
questions about failure of leadership
while sue gray says it in this report
but as we were talking about earlier the
critical thing here is
can it be put on the prime minister was
he responsible because the key thing in
all of this is
he said in december
there were no parties no one broke the
rules then he said he changed it
slightly he said i didn't break the
rules and then he said he wasn't aware
of events that happened that he thought
that gathering on may the 20th was a
work gathering no one told him
that it was not in the guidelines by
either the rules or the spirit of the
rules and that's the question about his
judgment it's not clear in this report
but i think the fact that this report
doesn't actually
have any detail means that the prime
minister is going to be under huge
pressure once this investigation has
concluded to come clean about what
happened in that place because sue gray
has not pulled her punches here saying
that these events some of them should
not have taken place and let's just
remember the met are now investigating
12 events this isn't a one-off they're
investigating 12 events and they only do
that
retrospectively if they think it's
syrian or serious enough in in a dozen
cases they think it is yeah quite
incredible that sue grey was only
allowed to mention four parties or
gatherings they were the ones that
deemed perhaps not to have broken the
rules and this update from sue gray had
much more she said bite than we expected
and in her conclusion she said there is
significant learning to be drawn from
these events which must be addressed
immediately across government this
doesn't need to wait for the police
investigations to be concluded because
what we do need hearing from
conservative mps and prime minister
itself is wait for the su great report
wait for the police investigation to be
finished sue grey hinting there that big
changes can be made
without reports being published yeah
look there's a couple of things that she
talks about in terms of the culture of
downing street which i think we can
explore one of them is she talks about
excessive consumption of alcohol
shouldn't happen in any workplace she
also talks about members of staff she
interviewed 70
people for this investigation she said
members of staff
were concerned but felt they couldn't
raise the concern so that's another
culture and leadership and leadership
issues yeah
so she talks about that and then she
says that some of this needs to be
addressed so that's the immediate
question uh does the prime minister go
in and announce an overhaul of this team
you'll want to get onto the front foot
my key question is is he going to commit
in the commons to actually publish in
the full report i think he's going to be
under huge pressure to do so he will
hope that he can kick the can down the
road perhaps that this will fade away
but now that the med are investigating a
dozen
parties in number 10 and
you know around whitehall that that
that's a big issue including one in his
own flat so i think there are obvious uh
questions to answer i know that there
will be questions in the comments about
is he shaking up his top team a lot of
those around him that support him feel
that boris johnson is the performer and
he needs this operation around him and
if the operation was better the
performance of the prime minister would
be better for his detractors who say
it's actually starts at the top and it's
his culture and that he quite likes
chaos this is what dominic commons would
argue that he wants to have a court in
which he is the king and there's
different factions of iron and it's a
quite chaotic
operation his supporters think if they
just get the support around him he can
do a better job his detractors would
argue
that this is the culture that he sets
and that it's not going to change even
if he shifts around
some of the key actors around him yeah
there might be some wiggle room for the
prime minister in the sentence that
there were failures of leadership and
judgment by different parts of number 10
and the cabinet office at different
times okay beth thank you we're going to
cross over to sam coates now a deputy
political editor who's in westminster
and got a first look at this report and
has been going through it because it you
know it may only be 12 pages some but
it
it has quite a lot of bite in it much
more so than we expected considering we
were told it was just an update
that's right sarah j one of the
fascinating things about today is that
until just maybe half an hour ago we
thought the lack of detail might help
boris johnson but now as he heads to the
commons it seems that that lack of
detail might just raise more questions
that boris johnson needs to answer in
this a 12-page report about 16 different
gatherings 12 of which are being
investigated by the metropolitan police
across eight different days let's take
you through some of the most significant
bits of the report and let's start at
the end with sugray's conclusions and
she says
that she has concluded a number of these
gatherings should not have been allowed
to take place or to develop in the way
that they did there is significant
learning to be drawn from these events
which must be addressed immediately
across government and here is the most
important sentence of this bit this does
not need to wait for the police
investigations to be concluded so this
is sue gray's first challenge to the
prime minister potentially say something
today when he hits the house of commons
about how he is going to change things
because the conclusions about number 10
could not be more damning and here we
are towards the end it seems at times
that too little thought was given to
what was happening across the country
considering the appropriateness of some
of these gatherings there were failures
of leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 and the cabinet
office at different times some of these
events to be able to take place other
events should not be allowed to develop
as they did now what do failures
of number 10 and the cabinet office
point to they point to blame for boris
johnson himself there is only one leader
in number 10 but it also points to
failures in the cabinet office who's
that well that's simon case he's the
cabinet secretary britain's most serious
most senior mandarin and he is being
named in this report as having failed in
his leadership so now let's look at some
more
sue gray makes absolutely clear in this
section that you're about to look at
that she wants her full conclusions out
in the public domain she says that as a
result of the met police investigation
she can't do a lot and it means that i
am extremely limited in what i can say
about these events and it's not possible
at present notice at present to provide
a meaningful report setting up and
analyzing existential extensive factual
information now look at this
extraordinary paragraph 13.
she says first of all i've given lots of
information to the police secondly i've
put it all in a safe and thirdly i have
not given it to boris johnson now sue
grey isn't saying she doesn't trust
boris johnson with the most sensitive
material at the heart of government
that's also linked to a police
investigation potentially about what
went on at his house but she's coming
very very close now let's look at this
what happened very close to home to
boris for boris johnson now you'll
remember you might not remember where
you were on the 13th of november 2020. i
do we were covering the departure from
number 10 of dominic cummings the in
fate of the notorious former aide uh to
the prime minister uh who has done more
to damage the prime minister's
reputation than anyone else outside of
government uh since leaving office on
that day he was seen leaving downing
street with a box of his possessions
what else was going on in downing street
that day a gathering not in the just the
number 10 offices but in the number 10
flat now this is what this is is a list
of the events that sue gray says were in
scope for her report in other words that
she was investigating we didn't think
necessarily that the events up in the
private flat of number 10 were going to
play a particular role in sue grey's
report because it is after all a private
uh a private residence but here it is
the flat boris johnson's personal flat
that he shares with carrie johnson is a
matter under investigation and it's not
in the list of um
of the various events that the
metropolitan police aren't investigating
so it would appear that sue gray is
looking into the flat and the police are
looking into what went on in the flat so
whether it is just 12 pages or not that
lack of detail but that firmness of
rhetoric is throwing the ball into the
prime minister's court there are many
many people on the prime minister's
shadow whipping operation on his private
team hopeful about today i'm not sure
that what's been delivered by su gray
will be brief is going to be
particularly as hopeful as he hoped
sam thank you very much indeed well in
the last few moments the prime minister
has left number 10 downing street and
headed to the house of commons he has
arrived there he will be making a
statement to the house at 3 30 so in
just over 15 minutes time you can watch
it live here on sky news the su great
update
has been released into the public domain
the prime minister has had it since this
morning he left it until quite late
for it to be released on the government
website but sam coats our deputy
political and i
political editor and i have been looking
through the general findings because
that's the meat of the 12-page document
against the backdrop of the pandemic
when the government was asking citizens
to accept far-reaching restrictions on
their lives some of the behavior
surrounding these gatherings is
difficult to justify sue grey goes on to
say at least some of the gatherings in
question represent a serious failure to
observe not just the high standards
expected of those working at the heart
of government
but also of the standards expected of
the entire british population at the
time i know that will resonate with so
many people watching at home who have
been telling their stories about what
they've been going through uh during the
national lockdowns here on sky news uh
see gray also says at times it seems
there was too little thought given to
what was happening across the country in
considering the appropriateness of some
of these gatherings the risk they
presented to public health and how they
might appear to the public these were
failures of leadership and judgment by
different parts of number 10 and the
cabinet office at different times they
are some of the general findings of sue
gray in her update that was given to
number 10 this morning we have our hands
on it now it's in the public domain our
deputy political editor sam coats is
still with us and sam there's a a line
in the conclusion from sue gray's update
that said
these events must be addressed
immediately across government this does
not need to wait for the police
investigations to be cl concluded so sue
gray
not only damning but saying get a move
on things can change or be done
immediately
that's right sarah jane i mean it's
pretty extraordinary to have
an official i mean she's a pretty
well-known and well-respected official
but an official nevertheless essentially
telling the prime minister to get a
wiggle on when it comes to overhauling
his entire government she seems to imply
that that's absolutely urgent and
necessary to restore trust in government
and restore the proper functioning
of government and she says do make
changes and make them now and given that
she's pointing the finger at uh
essentially at leadership failures in
number 10 uh he's got to set out why
people should have confidence in him but
she's also pointing out leadership
failures over in the cabinet office now
that's the place where government is
what is run from it's the center of
government could that mean curtains for
the cabinet secretary relatively newly
appointed simon case and what else might
he do in order to reset his
administration in order to uh try and
cling on uh to his premiership now boris
johnson's gonna have to address many of
these questions because he has committed
uh to go to the house of commons and
answer questions from mps uh we think at
about 3 30 so not long to go until he
does that and that means that we're
going to listen for a number of things
from mps how supportive are his mps when
they stand up behind him what changes
does he promise and how does he seem
does he look contrite or does he seem as
ground down as he did when he was
walking out of downing street just a few
minutes ago
sam thank you sam coats our deputy
political editor in our westminster
studio let's head to central lobby now
and joining us labour's deputy leader
angela rainer a good afternoon to you
angela rainer you've seen sue gray's
report what did you make of it
i found it really sickening and of
course this was not the full report this
was an update 12 of the 16 gatherings
are now being investigated by the police
and i find it utterly sickening that a
time where key workers were
dying on the front line their loved ones
were not able to say goodbye to them at
a funeral yet in downing street and in
number 10 they were having gatherings
and parties it is the most
fundamental failure of any prime
minister and i'm absolutely shocked that
boris johnson can even show his face in
parliament today if he stands up at that
dispatch box shortly the only things he
should be saying is how truly sorry he
is for letting down the british public
and he should be resigning because he
has lost the confidence of the british
people and he's failed in his number one
duty as a leader of our country and the
culture that was around number 10 at the
time which sue gray
so
um so starkly
says in her update was just shocking by
any standards
i think for many people the telling line
in the report there was no overt
criticism of the prime minister himself
but sugree you know the update wasn't
without bite and she said there were
failures of leadership and judgment by
different parts of number 10 and the
cabinet office at different times so not
direct criticism of
the prime minister himself but phase of
leadership is a big hint as to where
that buck stops
well the prime minister is the leader at
number 10 and the book stops with him
and like i said before this is only an
update and 12 of the 16 gatherings are
now subject to the police investigation
which is why sue gray couldn't give her
full report i think that's pretty
damning that we're in those
circumstances and the tone in which sue
gray sets out the complete fundamental
lack and failure of leadership
is pretty clear to me that the prime
minister is not fit to govern and it
would be astonishing to me if his
conservative colleagues prop him up now
when clearly he's lost the confidence of
the british public
many people that i've spoken to so far
this afternoon have said look it's not
going to change the prime minister isn't
going to stand up today and offer his
resignation he's not going to resign
it's in the hands very much of
conservative mps and i think as sue gray
and her report put it that you don't
need to wait for the conclusion of the
police investigation and to take
significant learnings from these events
that must be addressed immediately do
you think it's a case of deputy heads
will role
and then the prime minister will just
move on
i think that would be terrible for the
conservative party and mps to try and
blame civil servants when it is the
prime minister himself that has to take
responsibility here every day they keep
him in office knowing full well that
he's lost the confidence of the british
public is now not only a problem for
boris johnson becomes a problem for them
with their constituents because it's
triggering for people who lost their
loved ones who understood the rules who
abided by those rules and have seen a
prime minister who thinks he can lie his
way out of it misleading
because you do hear from many voters who
haven't been personally affected by
losing a loved one during lockdown or
not being able to go to a loved one's
funeral they empathize with those people
of course but they say look
look at the bigger picture boris johnson
the decisions he made during the
lockdown helped
keep my job helped keep my business
afloat a lot of people still back the
prime minister despite
what we now know factually happened
behind the door behind me
i've not met a single person that thinks
that what the prime minister did was the
right thing to do and the problem no but
you must let people who are willing to
take that on the chin and support him as
part of the wider picture
you know the one thing that i have heard
from people who are willing to say move
on and who are more sympathetic
the one thing that they can't get over
and what's really frustrating them now
is the fact not only did the prime
minister you know whether he knew he was
at a work event or not
that the fact that he thinks he could
just carry on now and lie to parliament
breach the ministerial code he's
literally doing damage to our democracy
now and that's when it bleeds into the
other issues that we've got you know
we're laughing stock abroad people are
talking about this worldwide you know
we've got all of these challenges we
face like the cost of living crisis the
energy situation the over 4 billion
pound of fraud that was written off by
the government of course i want to hold
him to his record on those things as
well but number one he had an obligation
to do the right thing by the british
public he's lost their trust and he has
to recognize that and if he had an ounce
of leadership in him he would recognise
that he's not fit to govern anymore he's
lost the confidence of the people and he
has to
go he is delivering his statement in
around 10 minutes time i know you're
going to want to go
to get into the chamber for that and
you've said what you want to hear from
him in his statement what are your
benches going to be saying to him in
reply
i think there's going to be a lot of
emotion obviously members of parliament
have also lost loved ones and had made
great sacrifices over that period but
they've had countless letters and emails
and constituents raising the trauma and
it is trauma of what they went through
during that period and the fact that the
prime minister continues to dismiss that
by thinking he can stay in office is
compounding that trauma for many people
so i think the number one i mean i'm
absolutely you know i have a feeling of
utter despair and upset that we're in
this circumstances and i feel for those
people who have made those sacrifices
who are witnessing that and who are
feeling angry and upset and frustrated
that the prime minister thinks that what
they went through was something that
he doesn't have to be accountable for
because he didn't care and he was
partying while they were losing their
loved ones restricted in their liberties
not seeing their family you know it's
just triggering the whole nation
of what they went through and the fact
that prime minister thinks he doesn't
have to abide by those rules
the longer this carries on for obviously
we've had the update we've talked about
the bike that that has despite it only
being a 12-page document we have the
metropolitan police investigation to be
concluded and then we may well have the
sue grey report in full um
the longer it goes on is the sting
coming out of the tail do you think in
terms of
boris johnson
not feeling the pressure as much and
being able to remain in his position is
that the worry for labour
i don't think i don't think it is i
think what actually is happening is now
bleeding into the conservative party and
conservative mps because you know before
it was a frustration and anger around
boris johnson's actions and his
leadership now it's a question of the
conservative party and their ability to
show their collective leadership of
putting the public good first and if
they choose to prop up the prime
minister when they know he's broke the
law when they know he's acted
inappropriately if they choose to try
and defend that then i think what
actually will happen is it will have a
devastating impact on the brand of
conservatives who have always prided
themselves on upholding the prince
british principles upholding the the law
of the country and i think it will start
to erode the trust and frustrate
conservative voters that they're
propping up boris johnson at a time when
actually what they want to do is move on
to these important issues that the
country faces
okay the prime minister delivering his
statement to the house of commons in six
minutes time angela rainer the deputy
leader of the labour party thank you
hope we've given you enough time to to
get in there to watch that statement and
respond of course let's just update
viewers on our breaking news sue grey's
investigation into allegations of
parties at downing street has been
published it is an update it's just 12
pages long
it's an abridged version
and there are some strong conclusions
we're waiting for a statement from the
prime minister as i said any minute now
we can take a closer look at some of the
detail in that 12-page report
it concludes there were failures of
leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 and the cabinet
office at different times it adds that
some events should not have been allowed
to take place others should not have
developed as they did it says that when
the government was asking citizens to
accept far-reaching restrictions on
their lives some of the behaviour
surrounding these gatherings is
difficult to justify
some staff wanted to raise concerns
about behaviors they witnessed at work
but at times felt unable to do so
the report adds that gatherings
represent a serious failure to observe
the high standards expected of those
working at the heart of government
and there was a lack of thought given in
considering the appropriateness of these
gatherings and finally sugree states
that an excessive consumption of alcohol
is not appropriate in a professional
workplace
uh joining me now katie balls deputy
political editor of the spectator now
katie before this update came out
everybody was saying oh it'll be a
bridge it'll be watered down might be 12
pages long but there's plenty of meat in
it yes and i think that because it has
been not redacted but we're getting a
summary as see grey put it when she
updated
um
jen
we ultimately are only seeing part of it
but i still think it's quite damning and
actually the impression i get from just
speaking to a few mps obviously it's
only been out um shortly is that they
think it's worse than they expected and
that's partly because everyone's saying
oh this is going to be the soft bit the
worst but still to come that makes it
out and actually sue grey's conclusions
i think about a failure of leadership
might not name boris johnson directly
but it clearly points to you know the
boss in that sense and secondly i think
if you look at the events the police are
investigating three of them include the
prime minister and one of them includes
the downing street flat and that raises
questions about whether boris johnson
has misled the house when he spoke about
that alleged event when he was asked
about it so lots more questions for
boris johnson actually raising more than
answers
what's in there is damning what's to
come could be even worse because we
mentioned that sugray couldn't talk
about certain gatherings because they
were part of the metropolitan police
investigation and when we know they're
around 16 to 17 she only mentioned four
so that's a number of parties that the
metropolitan police have to deal with
and there's a key paragraph in the
document that says um because of the
police investigation it's not possible
at present to provide a meaningful
report setting out and analyzing the
extensive factual information i've been
able to gather so that information is
now locked away do you think we're going
to see her findings in full boris
johnson has said he will publish them in
full could there be a change of heart
here at downing street now i think we've
been the mood music so far and some of
the suggestions from downing street have
been a little bit as though we know
we're not completely committing to the
second half wait for the police
investigation i think that the
government will have a big fight on its
hands if they try not if they try to
suppress the second part of that report
and partly because this summary begs so
many questions and it's actually just
more about you know what actually
happened at these events the prime
minister himself was at i think the
tricky thing is some of the events have
gone to the police are ones that he
attended so
it's not moving away from him something
he can talk about how it just as you
know his staff and he's changing the
culture there are questions about his
own behaviour yeah okay katie balton the
spectator thank you so much for joining
us here on downing street a morning
turning out to be a big day for the
prime minister
and we are hearing from
the prime minister himself in a couple
of minutes time he's going to give a
statement to the house of commons at 3
30. and sue gray's update uh her
abridged report that was released today
there's a a conclusion that says
there is significant learning to be
drawn from these events which must be
addressed immediately across government
this does not need to wait for the
police investigations to be concluded
our deputy political editor sam coates
is standing by and that might be the
sentence that's ringing in the prime
minister's ears as he heads the dispatch
box now
that's right i think there are a number
of things that we're going to look out
for in this
appearance by boris johnson it's going
to be a difficult appearance and there
was no doubting that as he walked out of
number 10 the
look on his face was not of somebody who
was on his way to be vindicated we're
going to be looking out for the mood on
the tory benches are they shocked at the
language you'll be able to see those uh
you can see all those back benches
sitting next to him
uh
you'll also get uh a chance to see what
his tone is uh is he contrite is there
another full apology does he announce
changes to his team to the government in
order to answer sue grey's call for
immediate change and then there's
another question which is how does the
leader of the opposition respond at
these moments if uh if the debate
becomes overly partisan if kiestama
stands up and just calls instantly uh
for boris johnson to resign then
sometimes that can uh pull in the troops
behind boris johnson uh will he try in
some ways to rise above that all of
those questions i think will be uh uh in
play at this really important
parliamentary moment which we're about
to witness
of course uh when boris johnson uh
arrives in the chamber and i don't think
that we can see uh that he's there yet
uh you will get a huge cheer hopefully
he will be hoping uh from his uh from
his back benches you can see there uh in
the picture on your screens that it is
one of those days where the chamber is
packed there are quite a few mps looking
uh on with folded arms never a
particularly good uh sign uh you've got
will quince is the uh is the uh person
you can see on your screen as he tries
to fill like we all are uh waiting for
the prime minister um but i think it is
that mood uh you saw last week when
boris johnson appeared uh essentially
quite a lot of
unhappy looks from the people sitting
either side of him the mood of the
cabinet i think will be incredibly
important the faces of the cabinet will
be scrutinized along with just more
generally the attitude of the
backbenchers uh has it been the case
that the chief whip has been able to
rally the troops get some supportive
questions uh in place or is it the case
that they're a little bit more uh a
little bit more muted
so we're gonna wait uh to measure uh the
cheers of the prime minister when he
arrives uh that's the uh speaker lindsey
hoyle uh uh addressing the chamber now i
don't think it's quite appropriate with
what i'm gonna say you ought to be
ashamed
i really don't kiss
before we move on to the first attempt i
would like to assure the house following
the comments made the start of questions
that there will be an opportunity to pay
tribute to our friend and colleague the
late jack jeromey
and that will take place on wednesday
i'm sure honourable and writerable
members will welcome the opportunity to
pay tribute at that point
i should inform the house that given the
brief period of time available to review
the report i shall be allowing the
leaders the opposition a little longer
to question the prime minister than is
usually the case and i'm sure the prime
minister way they wish a little longer
as well at the beginning i now come to
the statement prime minister
thank you very much mr speaker
mr speaker with your permission i would
like to make a statement and first i
want to express my
deepest gratitude to sue gray and all
the people who have contributed to this
report which i've placed in the library
of this house and which the government
has published in full today for everyone
to read
i will address its findings in this
statement
but firstly i want to say
sorry
and i'm sorry for the things we simply
didn't get right and also sorry for the
way that this matter has been handled
and it's no use
saying that this or that was within the
rules and it's no use saying that people
were working hard
this pandemic
was hard for everyone
we asked people across this country to
make the most extraordinary sacrifices
not to meet loved ones not to visit
relatives before they died and i
understand the anger that people feel
but mr speaker it isn't enough
to say sorry
this is a moment when let's look at
ourselves
in the mirror
and we must learn and while the
metropolitan police must yet complete
their investigation
and that means there are no details of
specific events in sue gray's report
i of course accept
sue gray's general findings in full
and above all her recommendation that we
must learn from these events and act now
with respect to the events under police
investigation she says and i quote
no conclusions should be drawn or
inferences made from this other than it
is now for the police to consider the
relevant material in relation to those
incidents but more broadly
she finds that there is significant
learning to be drawn from these events
which must be addressed immediately
across government
this does not need to wait for the
police investigations to be concluded
that is why we are making changes now
to the way downing street and the
cabinet office run
so that we can get on with the job the
job i was elected to do mr speaker and
the job that this government was elected
to do
[Applause]
first it is time to sort out what sue
grey rightly calls the fragmented and
complicated leadership structures of
downing street which she says have not
evolved sufficiently
to meet the demands of the expansion of
number 10
and we will do that
including by creating an office of the
prime minister with a permanent
secretary to lead number 10
[Music]
second mr speaker it is clear from sue
gray's report
that it is time not just to
review the civil service and special
advisor codes
of conduct
wherever necessary
to ensure that they take account of sue
gray's recommendations
but also to make sure that those codes
are properly enforced
and third
i will be saying more in the coming days
about the steps we will take to improve
the number 10 operation
and the work of the cabinet office
to strengthen
cabinet government
and to improve the vital connection
between
number 10
and parliament
mr speaker
i get it and i will fix it
[Applause]
i want to say
to the people of this country
i know
what the issue is
yes mr speaker yes
yes it's whether this government can be
trusted to deliver
and i say mr speaker yes we can be
trusted
yes we can be trusted to deliver we said
that we would get brexit done mr speaker
and we did
and we're setting up free ports around
the whole united kingdom i've been to
one of them today which is creating tens
of thousands of new jobs mr speaker we
said we would get this country through
covid and we did we delivered the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe and
the fastest booster program of any major
economy
so that we've been able to restore
people's freedoms faster than any
comparable economy
and at the same time we've been cutting
crime by fourteen percent building four
fourteen new hospitals and rolling out
gigabit broadband mr speaker and
delivering all the promises of our 2019
agenda so that we have the fastest
economic growth of the g7 we have
shown that we have done things that
people thought were impossible mr
speaker and
and that we can deliver for the british
people mr speaker
i just i remind the adventures opposite
the reason we're coming out of covid so
fast is at least partly because we
doubled the speed of the booster rollout
and i can tell the house
and this country
that we are going to bring the same
energy and commitment to getting on with
the job to delivering for the british
people and to our mission to unite and
level up across this country mr speaker
and i commend this statement to the
house
[Applause]
i don't call kirsten the leader of the
opposition
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
sue gray for the diligence and
professionalism with which she's carried
out her work it's no fault of hers that
she's only been able to produce an
update today not the full report
the prime minister repeatedly assured
the house that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed
but we now know
that 12 cases have reached the threshold
for criminal investigation
which i remind the house
means that there is evidence of serious
and flagrant breaches of lockdown
including including the party on the
20th of may 2020 which we know the prime
minister attended
and the party on the 13th of november
2020 in the prime minister's flat
there can be no doubt that the prime
minister himself is now subject to
criminal investigation
the prime minister must keep his promise
to publish sue grey's report in full
when it is available
but it is already clear that the report
discloses the most damning conclusion
possible
over the last two years the british
public have been asked to make the most
heart-wrenching sacrifices
a collective trauma
endured by all
enjoyed by none
funerals have been missed dying
relatives unvisited
every family has been marked by what
we've been through
and revelations about the promised
behavior have forced us all to rethink
and relive those darkest moments
many have been overcome by rage
by grief
and even guilt
guilt
that because they stuck to the law they
did not see their parents one last time
guilt that because they didn't bend the
rules
their children went months without
seeing friends
guilt that because they did as they were
asked they didn't go and visit lonely
relatives
but people shouldn't feel guilty
they should feel pride
in themselves and their country because
by abiding by those rules
they've saved the lives of people they
will probably never meet
they have shown the deep public spirit
and the love and respect for others that
has always characterized this nation at
its best
our national story about covert is one
of the people that stood up when they
were tested
but that will be forever tainted by the
behavior of this conservative prime
minister
by routinely breaking the rules he set
the prime minister took us all for fools
he held people sacrificing contempt he
showed himself unfit for office
his desperate denials since he was
exposed have only made matters worse
rather than come clean every step of the
way he's insulted the public's
intelligence
and now he's finally fallen back on his
usual excuse
it's everybody's fault but his
they go
he stays
even now he is hiding behind a police
investigation into criminality into his
home and his office
[Applause]
mr speaker he gleefully treats what
should be a mark of shame as a welcome
shield but prime minister the british
public aren't fools they never believed
a word of it
they think the prime minister should do
the decent thing and resign
[Music]
of course he won't
because he is a man without shame
and just as he has done throughout his
life he's damaged everyone and
everything around him along the way
his colleagues have spent weeks
defending the indefensible touring the
tv studios parroting his absurd denials
degrading themselves and their offices
fraying the bond of trust between the
government oh
the member so thribble is my neighbor i
expect better from my neighbors
kirsten
fraying the bond of trust between the
government and the public eroding our
democracy and the rule of law
margaret thatcher once said
the first duty of government is to
uphold the law
if it tries to bob and weave and duck
around that duty when it's inconvenient
then so will the governed
mr speaker
to govern this country is an honor not a
birthright
it is an act of service to the british
people not the keys to a court to parade
to your friends
it requires honesty
integrity a moral authority
i can't tell you how many times people
have said to me that this prime
minister's lack of integrity is somehow
priced in
that is behavior and character don't
matter
i have never accepted that and i never
will accept that
whatever your politics whichever party
you vote for honesty and decency matters
our great democracy depends on it
and cherishing and nurturing british
democracy is what it means to be
patriotic
there are members opposite who know that
and they know the prime minister is
incapable of it
the question they must now ask
themselves is what are they going to do
about it
[Music]
they can heap their reputations the
reputation of their party the reputation
of this country on the bonfire that is
his leadership
or they can spare the country from a
prime minister totally unworthy of his
responsibilities
[Applause]
it is their duty to do so
they know better than anyone how
unsuitable he is for high office
many of them knew in their hearts that
we would inevitably come to this one day
and they know that as night follows day
continuing his leadership will mean
further misconduct cover-up and deceit
it is only they that can end this pass
the eyes of the country are upon them
they will be judged by the decisions
they take now
[Applause]
well mr speaker
there's a reason why he said absolutely
nothing about the report
that was presented
by this government and later put in the
library of the house early on say that
is because mr speaker the report does
absolutely nothing to substantiate the
tissue of nonsense that he has just
spoken
absolutely absolutely
instead mr speaker this this leader of
the opposition a former director of
public prosecutions mr speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile as far as i can make up mrs
speaker
he mr speaker chose to use it chose to
use this moment he used this moment mr
speaker
continually to pre-judge a police
inquiry that's what he chose to do
he's reached his conclusions about it
i'm not going to reach any conclusions
and he would be entirely and entirely
wrong to do so and and i direct him
again mr speaker to what uh sue gray
says in her in her report about the
conclusions that can be drawn uh from uh
her inquiry about what the police may or
may not do now mr speaker i have
complete confidence uh in the police and
i hope that they will uh they will be
allowed simply to get on with their job
and i don't propose to offer any more
commentary about it and i don't believe
that he should either and i must say to
him uh that what i think the current and
well i think the country with greatest
respect to the ventures opposite what i
think the country wants us all in this
house to focus on
is the issues that matter to them
[Applause]
getting on mr speaker we're taking this
country forward and and mr speaker uh
today
we have delivered yet more brexit
freedom to the new freeport
in tilbury as i said when he voted 48
times to take this country back into the
uh to the eu
uh mr speaker we have the most open
society most open economy is mr speaker
this is i think what people want us to
focus on we are the most open society
most open economy in europe because of
the vaccine rollout because of the
booster relief and never forget mr
speaker that he voted he voted to keep
us in the european medicine agency which
would make that impossible and today mr
speaker we are standing together with
our nato allies against the potential
aggression of vladimir putin when he
wanted not so long ago to install a
prime minister as prime minister a
labour leader who would actually have
abolished nato mr speaker that's what he
believes in those are his priorities
what i can say to him he can continue
with his political opportunism we are
going to get on and i am going to get on
with the job
quiet
theresa may thank you mr speaker
the covet regulations impose significant
restrictions on the freedoms of members
of the public
they had a right to expect their prime
minister
to have read the rules to understand the
meaning of the rules and indeed those
around them to have done around him to
have done so too
and to set an example in following those
rules what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him
or they didn't think the rules applied
to number 10 which was it
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
a very important question i want to hear
the answer even if other people don't
prime minister
uh no mr speaker that is not what the uh
grey report says
[Applause]
[Music]
but if she i i i
suggest that she waits to see uh the
conclusion of the inquiry
[Music]
i now come to the leader of the snp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker can i say it's a
pleasure to follow the
former prime minister and perhaps
her behavior in office like many that
went before him was about dignity about
the importance of the office of respect
of truthfulness and the prime minister
would be well advised to focus on those
that have not dishonored the office like
he has done
mr speaker
we stand here today
faced with the systematic decimation of
public trust in government and the
institutions of the state
and at its heart
a prime minister
a prime minister
being investigated
by the police
so here we have it
the long-awaited sue gray report what a
farce
it was
carefully engineered to be
a fact-finding exercise
with no conclusions
now we find
it's a fact-finding exercise with no
facts
so
let's talk facts
the prime minister has told the house
that
all guidance was completely followed
there was no party
covert rules were followed in that
i believed it was a work event
nobody
nobody believed them then
and nobody
nobody believes you're now prime
minister
that is the crux
no ifs no buts
he has willfully willfully misled
parliament
it's bad enough
order
[Applause]
in a burden misled your house would be
acceptable misled the houses
[Applause]
withdraw inverted
the prime minister inadvertently told
the house in the 8th of december that no
parties had taken place and then had to
admit that they had
it's bad enough mr speaker that the
prime minister's personal integrity is
in the ditch
but this murky business is tainting
everything around it it is our intention
to submit a motion instructing the prime
minister to publish the great report in
full
well the prime minister
of being instruction by this house to
publish as required
mr speaker
amidst allegations of blackmail by tory
whips
the members opposite have been defending
the indefensible
wait for the report we were told
well here it is
and it tells us very little except it
does state
that there were failures of leadership
and judgment by different parts of
number 10.
it states that some events should not
have been allowed to take place
that is the prime minister's
responsibility
if there is any honor
any honor in public life
then he would resign
[Music]
where is this
and he'll ask
and the prime minister laughs
we ought to remind ourselves in this
house
and 150 000 plus of our citizens have
lost their lives
family members that couldn't be with
them and that is the site that people
will remember a prime minister laughing
at our public i extend the hand of
friendship
to all those that have sacrificed i
certainly do not extend the hand of
friendship to the prime minister who is
no friend of mine
[Music]
where is the shame
where is the dignity
meanwhile the police investigation will
drag on and on
every moment the prime minister stays
trust in government and the rule of law
is ebbing away the litany of rule
breaking the culture of contempt the
utter disdain for the anguish felt by
the public who have sacrificed so much
what the public see
is a man who has debased the office of
prime minister shrinked responsibility
dogged accountability and blamed his
staff at every turn presiding over
slaves and corruption and tainted the
very institutions of the state in short
mr speaker this is a man
[Applause]
well they can laugh
they can laugh
but the public know
the public know this is a man they can
no longer trust
he has been investigated by the police
he misled the house he must now resign
honor
you'll have to withdraw that last
comment
mr speaker i gave the evidence of the
8th of december
you're going to have to withdraw misled
mr speaker the prime minister has misled
the house
[Applause]
unless you withdraw i will have to stop
and that's not good just withdraw the
words
i am standing up for my constituents
that know that this prime minister has
lied and misled the house
give me the paper
give me the paper
i'll give you one more chance as leader
of the snp i don't want to have to throw
you out i'm going to give you this
chance please increase the power that
man has left the house
i'm sorry it's come to this
and i'm sorry the leader of the party
has not got the decentred just withdraw
those words in order that this debate
can be represented by all political
leaders
would you like to inadvertently
speak if the prime minister has
inadvertently misled the house then i
will state that right we're going to
leave it at that
prime minister
mr speaker
i'm
grateful to the uh right honourable
general withdrawing uh what he just said
because he was wrong then and uh he i'm
afraid is wrong in the in his his
analysis and i i i apologize as i've
said for uh all the suffering that
people have had throughout this pandemic
and uh and for the anger that people
feel
about uh what has taken place in in
number 10 down in the street but i've
got i've got to tell
the uh the right honourable gentleman
that for much of what he said his best
course is simply to wait for the uh for
the inquiry to be complete
can i just say i take it the honourable
member that's withdrawn the right to
remember
that the prime minister may have
inadvertently misled the house
but
to help me to help the house you
withdraw your early comments and replace
it with inadvertently it's not my fault
if the prime minister can't be trusted
[Applause]
under the power given to me by standing
order number 43 i ordered the honourable
member to withdraw immediately from the
house
it's all right we don't need to bother
right let us move on andrew mitchell
does my right honourable friend recall
that
ever since he joined the party's
candidates list 30 years ago
until we got him into number 10 he has
enjoyed
my full-throated support
but i am deeply concerned by these
events and i'm very concerned indeed by
some of the things he has said from that
dispatch book and has said to the
british public and our constituents
when he kindly invited me to see him 10
days ago
i told him that i thought he should
think very carefully about what was now
in the best interests of our country and
of the conservative party and i have to
tell him he no longer enjoys my support
well uh
mr speaker i i must tell respectfully uh
my right honourable friend great though
uh the admiration uh is that i have of
him i i simply think that he's uh
mistaken in his views and uh i i urge
him to i urge him to to reconsider upon
full consideration of the of the inquiry
demands the riedel
thank you very much uh mr speaker
the prime minister
told us and i'm quoting him i have
repeatedly been assured since these
allegations emerged that there was no
party and that no covet rules were
broken
we now know that
12 of the 16 parties are subject to a
police investigation
and that of the remaining four the su
grey report says this that she's seen a
serious failure to observe the high
standards at number 10. she's seen
failures of leadership
failures of judgment
and
the prime minister thinks this is fine
so just how bad do things have to be
before he takes personal responsibility
does what everybody in this country
wants him to do and
resign mr speaker what we are doing is
taking the action that i've described uh
to set up a prime minister's department
to improve the operation of number 10
and we will be taking further steps mr
speaker in uh in the days ahead
remember
speaker the uh inquiry has found there
have been serious failings and has
suggested there'd be changes in the the
way that uh number 10 is run and there's
a real opportunity now to take forward
this new office of the prime minister
and ensure further improvements are made
so that we can carry on delivering
because what the party's opposite hate
is the fact that this government will
carry on delivering on the things that
matter most to people while also making
sure that the government's within number
10 is improved
i thank my right honorable friend very
very much i think he's completely right
i do think that
the opposition of course uh want to keep
the uh their focus trained on this
that's the that's their decision i think
mr speaker i think mr speaker what the
people in this country want us to do is
to get on with the job that they want us
to do and that is to serve them mr
speaker and to stop talking frankly
about ourselves
[Applause]
mr speaker there is no word in the
english language for a parent who has
lost a child
no equivalent of widow or orphan for
that particular horror
it is a loss that is literally beyond
words
a loss that hundreds and thousands of
parents
have tragically experienced during this
pandemic
many had to bury their children alone
many couldn't be there with them at the
end
meanwhile
number 10 parted
does the prime minister understand
does he care about the enormous hurt his
actions have caused to bereave families
across our country
will he finally accept
that the only decent thing that he can
do now
is to resign
mr speaker i do
care deeply about the hurt that is felt
across the country
uh about the suggestion that uh things
were going on in number 10 that were in
contravention of the of the copied rules
and i understand how deeply people feel
about this and how angry uh that they
are and i and i've apologized uh several
times mr speaker but i must say that i
think we should wait for the outcome of
the inquiry by before jumping to the
conclusions uh that he has and in the
meantime we should focus on the issues
that matter to the british people
line notes
speaker the public and this house have
been frustrated by having to wait for
sugray wait for the metropolitan police
and today the prime minister has
announced his new office at number 10.
please can you let this house know what
specific structures are going to be put
in place
so that this house can hold it
accountable
well mr speaker we will make sure that
there's a new permanent secretary uh to
who will be accountable uh to me uh and
we will make sure that the codes of
conduct that are applied both to spads
and to uh civil servants are properly
enforced and of course uh all of that
will be properly communicated to the to
the house mr speaker and what i want to
see is much better uh communication and
uh and links between a number 10 and the
entirety of the house of commons and we
will do that so george howard
thank you mr speaker yesterday
at the local
tesco store in my constituency
a constituents asked me and it was in a
tone more in sorrow than in anger
why doesn't the prime minister realize
that as every day goes by
he damages the reputation of our country
and
abroad and around the world
why he said doesn't the prime minister
realize that how would he respond to
that constituent
mr speaker i think the reputation of our
country around the world is built on the
fastest vaccine rollout uh in
europe in all major economies uh it is
built on having the fastest growth
therefore in the g7 and it is built on
our ability to bring bring our allies
together to stand up against vladimir
putin that is what the world is focused
on that is what i am focused on and that
frankly is what he should be focused on
so brenda jenkin
thank you uh mr speaker can my right
honourable friend first of all
uh remind the leader of the opposition
and the labour party that the
backbenchers of the conservative party
need no reminders about how to dispose
of a failing leader
[Music]
and can he
can he
can he also
can he also
when he is restructuring number 10
concentrate on the fact that the country
wants results
the country we can't see the point of
such a large number 10 superstructure
that it needs to be slimmed down and
streamlined and can i commend his
determination to restore
to restore cabinet to restore cabinet
government and it is on results over the
next few months on which he will be
judged
well mr speaker i thank you uh my ronald
friend very much for that and i i think
he's entirely right and i'm uh more than
content to be judged mr speaker on the
results that we've already delivered in
the results that we will deliver i'm
sure that we will be greatly assisted uh
by the reforms of number 10 of the live
outline diane abbott
thank you mr speaker
anybody who's actually read the su grey
report
can only wonder what she was made to
leave out
will the prime minister give the house
an undertaking that as soon as he is
able he will release the full
unredacted report to this house
uh
mr speaker sue gray has published uh
everything uh that she can and i propose
that we wait until the conclusion of the
of the inquiry uh but in the meantime mr
speaker i think it uh i think peculiar
that the report is being simultaneously
uh hailed as utterly damning uh but also
uh condemned for not uh having enough in
it um
it can't be both
vital fabric
president truman had on his desk the
buck stops here
so the prime minister was right to
apologize for the events that happened
in number 10 downing street
two weeks ago
i reminded tom harwood that tony blair
suggested that there should be an office
of prime minister so that it could be
governed not from 70 whitehall but from
the building itself
could the prime minister tell me how he
envisions the office will work will the
permanent secretary be based in number
10 controlling what civil servants do in
number 10.
uh very grateful i think the house does
understand even if many people outside
uh don't the number 10 actually uh
hosts about more than 400 officials uh
on a on a busy day they have a huge
amount to do and and we need to make
sure we need to make sure
no mr speaker they're working very hard
that's what they're doing
and and we need to make sure
that there are proper lines of authority
and that we sort out the the command
structures and that's what we're doing
overlams
yeah yeah thank you mr speaker
whatever the police decide this uh
update
limited as it is would be enough to
persuade any other prime minister to
resign
this prime minister could resign and
salvage salvage for himself a [ __ ] or two
of honor
or he may try to dismay to delay and
take his party down with him
so mr speaker is it not clear
that's with notable exceptions
his backbenchers should discover their
backbones and suckin
mr speaker i've i've answered several
questions like that and i just i must
really ask him to look at the uh report
properly and also to wait uh for the
inquiry when it comes i'll garper thank
you very much um mr speaker
we've been asked to keep some sense of
perspective and i think that's right
the question here
is whether those who make the law obey
the law that's pretty fundamental um
many have questioned including some of
my constituents the prime minister's
honesty and integrity and fitness to
hold that office now in judging him he
rightly asked us
to wait for all the facts
sue gray has made it clear in her update
today that she couldn't produce a
meaningful report with the fans so can i
ask the prime minister the question that
the honourable lady the member for
hackney north and stoke newington asked
him into which he didn't give an answer
when sue gray produces
all of the facts
in her full report after the police
investigation will he commit
to publish it immediately
and in full
speaker what we've got to do that's who
great is is wait for the
wait for the wait uh wait for the police
to conclude their inquiries mr speaker
that is the proper thing to do people
have given uh all sorts of evidence to
the expectation that it would not
necessarily uh be published mr speaker
at that stage i will take a decision
about what to publish mr speaker
thank you mr speaker um i imagine that
i'm going to be asked to wait for
something else
um but can i just simply ask the prime
minister
was the prime minister present at the
event in his flat
on the 13th
of november i assume he doesn't need
other people to tell him whether he was
there or not
um was he at the flat event listed in
the report on the 13th of november
mr speaker i'm very grateful to the uh
honorable lady for inviting me to to
comment on something that is
being investigated uh but i i
i with great respect to her i am
certainly not going to indulge in
running comedy she will have to wait mr
speaker
sir
mr
speaker
saying
sorry is very important
but my right honourable friend will be
judged by the deeds that he undertakes
as a result i heard today
a proper acknowledgement that he needs
to look in the mirror
and i'm glad to hear about reforms to
the center of government that i think
are timely in fact they're over due as
he knows from previous conversations
i've had with him but will he give me
and the house this undertaking today
that in cooperating with the
metropolitan police inquiry he will show
the appropriate tone and approach that i
think the british public demand of him
uh as as a person of serious purpose who
is up to the level of events that's what
we expect from him now and that's what
i'll be expecting him to do i i thank my
writer my friend very much and i just
want to stress mr speaker that i i have
great admiration for the metropolitan
police and full confidence in the police
and i i i just suggest that they'd be
allowed now to get on with their job
culture thank you mr speaker we now know
that there's a criminal investigation
into the party that took place on the
13th of november
2020
in his flat
to celebrate the exit of mr cummings
on the 8th of december last year
he came to that dispatch box
and flatly denied
the very idea that any
such party had taken places shaking his
head in answer to my honorable friend
the member for hornsey and wood green he
said it had not happened
now it's inadvertently
mr speaker
misled the house
so the very least he should do is get to
that dispatch box
and correct
the record
[Applause]
no mr speaker i stand by what i said and
i would urge and i would simply urge him
i would simply urge him to wait for the
outcome of the of the inquiry that's
what he needs to do
thank you mr speaker
may i advise my right honourable friend
publicly
what i have said to emissaries from his
campaign team privately
that it is truly in his interest
in the government's interest and in the
national interest that he should insist
on receiving the full unredacted report
immediately as i believe he can and that
he should then publish the uncensored
version without any further delay
well i i'm very grateful to my right
honourable friend but i think extensive
legal advice has been taken uh on this
point and uh sue gray has published
everything that she thinks she can that
is consistent with that advice
mr speaker um if the police
investigation were to result in serious
criminal charges
necessitating a criminal trial such as i
don't know for example misconduct in
public office
or conspiracy to pervert the course of
justice
how would the prime minister feel about
having to give evidence on oath
mrs seriously i'm not going to speculate
about
hypothetical uh
uh
uh questions which which frankly i
reject
well blood job
mr speaker you all know that it's a very
rare event for any prime minister to
come to this house and apologize a
difficult thing
for any prime minister
to do
but on the issue of the police
investigation does my right honourable
friend agree with me that there should
be due process that there should be free
and unfettered access to all at number
10 but most of all there should be no
prejudging or undermining of the police
inquiry before it's concluded
[Music]
yes i i completely agree and i must say
i'm shocked by some of the commentary
that i've heard from the benches
opposite about that matter today mr
speaker
chris brown
thank you mr speaker the thing is
this is who the prime minister
is a serious failure to observe high
standards
failures of leadership and judgment
excessive consumption of alcohol in a
professional workplace gatherings that
shouldn't not have been able to take
place
staff too frightened to raise concerns
parties in his own private flat
a leopard doesn't change its spots
does it
every single one who defends this
will face this again and again
and again
because he still won't even admit to the
house that when he came to us
on the 13th of november and said the
guidance and the rules were followed at
all times
and on the 1st of december that all the
guidelines were observed
that those things simply were not true
if you won't
correct the record today
there's nothing
accidental about this is there
it's deliberate
[Applause]
i don't know what he's
trying to say mr speaker but
look look i i direct him again to the uh
point made by sue gray that no
conclusions should be drawn or
inferences made from this other than it
is now time for the police to consider
the relevant material and that is what
the house should allow them frankly to
do
speaker
it is absolutely right that over the
past few weeks
our constituents across the house
have been writing to us on this hugely
important issue
and i don't in any way wish to minimize
its importance
but in my constituency i have military
bases
and i am receiving emails from families
who are concerned about their loved ones
and the potential role they may end up
playing given the conflict on the
russian ukrainian border
members opposite may
treat this lightly but for the families
but families who have those serving in
the military do not treat it lightly
would my right honourable friend
give me an assurance
that notwithstanding the importance of
the issue that we are discussing at
present his government will start
addressing other important matters that
concern my constituents and the
constituents of people across this house
thank him very much indeed and i think
he's completely right that the of course
these matters are important we've forgot
to wait for the uh for the inquiry but
in the meantime the uk has got to play
uh the leading role that we are mr
speaker in bringing the west together to
make a united front against vladimir
putin particularly with the economic
sanctions that we need mr speaker that
is uh the priority of the government
right now colin mason
mr speaker while the prime minister was
eating birthday cake with his pals
people were standing outside nursing uh
home windows looking in at their loved
ones dying and contrary to what the
prime minister has said from that very
dispatch spots multiple times any
objective reading of sue gray's update
makes it absolutely clear that the rules
were broken multiple times in downing
street will the prime minister continue
a habit of a lifetime and keep blaming
everybody else or will he finally stand
up take responsibility and just go
[Music]
uh mr speaker he's really got to read
the report and he's got it he's got to
look at the report and he's got he's got
to wait this is all everything he said
i'm afraid he's not substantiated by the
report uh he should look uh and wait for
the uh for the police inquiry
steve baker thank you mr speaker
millions of people millions of people
took seriously a communications campaign
apparently designed by behavioral
psychologists to bully to shame and to
terrify them into compliance with minute
restrictions on their freedom
what is my right honourable friends
central message
to those people who meticulously
complied with all of the rules
and suffered terribly for it including i
might say those people whose mental
health will have suffered appallingly as
a result of the messages his government
was sending out
mr speaker i want to thank all those
people
for everything that they did
because together uh they have helped us
to control uh coronavirus and i think
thanks to their amazing actions in
coming forward uh to get vaccinated
we're now in a far better position than
many other countries around the world so
i have a massive debt of gratitude to
all the people that he describes then
diana johnson
asked by my honorable friend and member
for birmingham yardley i'm not asking
for a running commentary but i would
like to know whether the prime minister
was present in his flat at the event on
the 13th of november 2020.
[Music]
i i'm really grateful to mr speaker i
understand why people want me to
elaborate on all sorts of points but i
am not going to make a running
commentary on a matter that is now being
uh considered uh by the authorities i
gotta wait for them to conclude
andrew jones mr speaker the update that
we have from sue grey today is that she
says herself extremely limited and that
it is not possible at present to provide
a meaningful report so will my rightful
friend confirm that at the earliest
opportunity he will have the report
published in fall
oh mr speaker what we will do is uh wait
until the police have concluded uh their
inquiries and then see what more
we can publish that is what we're going
to do
catherine west
thank you very much mr speaker as the
prime minister will recall on the eighth
of december in prime minister's
questions i asked him
was there a party in downing street on
the 13th of november
and now the report says in the bullet
point on the first page that there was a
gathering in the number 10 downing
street flat a gathering in the number 10
downing street on the departure of a
special adviser
did he
inadvertently mislead this house put us
all out of our agony and stop dragging
democracy through the mud yeah
mr speaker i i
i stick by what i said to her and she
should wait uh if she cares about
democracy and due process she should
wait until until the inquiry has been
concluded
mark jenkins
thank you mr speaker as a non-drinker
who long ago realized that sobriety
delivers everything that alcohol
promised i've noticed with interest
that a drinking culture exists in
downing street and in fact pre-dates my
right honourable friend's tenure by some
decades
does he
like me welcome sue grey's report and
will he commit to fixing that culture
yes mr speaker i thank you very much and
uh we're certainly mr speaker going to
take up uh the relevant parts of her
recommendations and see that they're
properly enforced within the civil
service in this bad code
lucas
thank you very much mr speaker the
shocking incompetence of the met police
has meant that we have a report that has
been gutted but frankly we didn't need
sue grey to tell us about the level of
dishonor and deception that has infected
not only downing street but so many in
the party opposite it has been
excruciating to watch so many tory mps
and ministers
willing to defend the indefensible
calculating what's in their own party
political interests rather than what's
right for our country complicit in the
same decaying system where the pursuit
of power trumps integrity the prime
minister is certainly a bad apple but
the whole tree is rotten and the whole
country wants reform
couldn't we make a start with a major
overhaul of the ministerial code given
that its founding assumption that it
could be policed by a prime minister of
the day because they would be a person
of honesty and integrity
that founding assumption has been so
widely and comprehensively and utterly
discredited
uh mr speaker uh of all the things that
she just we are reforming the
ministerial code but of all the things
that i disagree with her
about it and what she's just said i
disagree with her most passionately in
what she's just said about the police i
think they do an outstanding job i think
we should allow them to get on with that
job and i will await their conclusions
okay doyle price thank you mr speaker if
i just uh draw attention to finding
number seven uh in this report which
documents that actually number ten
downstream has more from a small team in
support of the prime minister to a
self-indulgent bureaucracy all its own
and i personally am tired of reading
sunday newspapers which read on
officials briefing against ministers
delays by things being stuck in number
10 as i speak to ministers who are
getting frustrated so
can i ask my right-hand friend that as
he institutes this review call me
old-fashioned but ministers are
accountable for decisions and that
they're taking taken in their name not
flunk is in number 10 and will he ensure
that reforms properly restore
ministerial accountability yes
i i thank her very much and i very much
enjoyed our joint trip to uh tilbury uh
this morning and i can tell her that yes
i do think that it's vital as sue grace
says that we learn from this and that we
strengthen a cabinet government and the
principle of ministerial responsibility
thank you mr speaker
i have spoken about my own experience of
loss during the pandemic many times
i do not claim that my experience are
special
indeed they were all too common
but as a member of parliament i have a
responsibility to provide a voice for
the briefed families
make no mistake
this report is utterly damning and
suggests that the prime ministers and
the government's actions were a risk to
public health
how on earth
can the prime minister stand there and
justify this
does he now accept that his actions were
a complete and absolute failure of
leadership and judgment
mr speaker i thank him very much i
repeat what i've said that i am deeply
sorry for all the suffering there's been
throughout this pandemic whether of his
constituents or anyone uh in the in the
country uh as to his his points about uh
what is in the report i don't think his
views are substantiated by the uh by
what the report says but i think he
should wait he should wait to see uh
where the inquiry goes and that's what i
propose to do
somewhere thank you mr speaker does my
right hand agree with me that those
opposite have used far too much time too
far too much parliamentary time debating
this and i can assure my right and my
friends that the residents established
the residents established they want the
prime minister to focus on the matters
that really they care about just in just
a moment
in furnace the prime minister has to
come and make the statement no i'm not
going to attack the prime minister we're
making this thing i certainly won't
expect him from his own side
thank you mr speaker i think possibly
what my and i want to say how strongly i
agree with my uh nonetheless with my my
honourable friend because uh because yes
of course uh it's it's vital that we
make this statement yes of course it's
vital that we uh learn from sue gray's
report vital that we take action uh mr
speaker which is what the government is
doing but it's also vital frankly that
we get on with the people's priorities
and that is what this government is also
doing christian matherson thank you mr
speaker so just to summarize we've had i
didn't know there was a party um there
wasn't the party but it was a work
meeting um and um there was a party but
um i wasn't there um
why is it the prime minister mentioned
international negotiations why should
anybody any country any government with
whom we enter into negotiations deals
at all and take take um any kind of uh
word from a government that clearly acts
with mendacity of foresaw therefore
thought from start to beginning
uh well mr speaker uh this is the
government that took this country out of
the eu and did what was necessary and
this is the government uh that is
bringing uh the west together to stand
up against vladimir putin and those
those are the those are the important
considerations as for the rest of what
he said mr speaker it's nonsense but he
should wait for the police inquiry holly
bobby croft
speaker my constituents in scotland are
very keen to see the industrial energy
prices fixed will the prime minister
reassure me that he will not be
distracted by any of this and that he
will get on with the job and come
forward with a solution to that issue
yes i think my honorable friend is
completely right we not only need to
address uh consumer energy costs we need
to address uh address business and
industrial energy costs as well
and i know that uh my rather friend uh
the chancellor uh is will be bringing
forward a package of measures uh as soon
as he can
custodial
mr speaker
mr speaker during his statement the
prime minister kept referring to we
when he talked about the sorry saga that
sue grey has reported
but mr speaker it's his rules it's his
rule breaking it's his inability to tell
the truth about it that's the issue he's
the prime minister does he not take any
personal responsibility at all for this
disgraceful fiasco
mr speaker i've taken full
responsibility throughout the pandemic
richard feller
speaker as with the report on owen
patterson i felt it was important to
support the process
and read the report
and that's because i think it's
important to separate fact from
allegation
and to know what the report actually
says rather than what i would wish it to
say
two lessons that the leader of the
opposition needs to learn
i promised my constituents that i would
ask the prime minister to say that he
would support the recommendations in the
report there are four that every
government department has a clear and
robust policy in place covering the
consumption of alcohol in the workplace
that access to the garden including for
meetings should be invitation only and
uncontrolled environment that there
should be easier ways for staff to raise
such concerns basically whistleblowing
and that too much responsibility and
expectation is placed on the senior
official whose principal function is the
direct support of the prime minister
those are the facts and the findings of
the report will the prime minister
accept in full yeah yes uh yes mr
speaker i i do and as i've said to the
house earlier on i accept the findings
of the report in full uh the general
findings and uh we we are immediately
taking steps to implement the changes
[Applause]
the prime minister's just said he
accepts the findings of the report
one of them
says that there were failures of
leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 the cabinet office at
different times he provides the
political leadership and the political
judgement and number 10 does he accept
his own personal wrongdoing and failings
in this regard
[Applause]
mr speaker not only have i accepted full
responsibility uh throughout uh but i i
have apologized uh repeatedly to the
house for any misjudgments that i may
have made myself but again i must urge
her to wait for the conclusion of the
inquiry
erin bell
it seems a lot of people attended events
in may 2020 the one i recall attending
was my grandmother's funeral she was a
wonderful woman as well as a love for
her family she served her community as a
counselor and she served art for
conservative association loyally for
many years i drove for three hours from
staffordshire to kent
only 10 people at the funeral many
people who loved her had to watch online
i didn't hug my siblings i didn't hug my
parents i gave a eulogy
and then afterwards i didn't even go to
her house for a cup of tea i drove back
three hours from kent to staffordshire
does the prime minister think i'm a fool
no mr speaker i want to thank my
honourable friend and i want to i want
to say how deeply i sympathize with him
uh and his family uh for their loss uh
and all i can say is
again that
i'm very very sorry for misjudgments
that may be made in uh by me or anybody
else in number 10
and the cabinet office and i i can only
uh ask him respectfully uh mr speaker to
look at what sue gray has said but also
to look at the to wait for the
conclusion of the inquiry
thank you mr speaker it's important that
this house can trust what ministers tell
us from that dispatch box and on the 8th
of december regarding events at number
10 downey street the minister the prime
minister said i repeat that i've been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged that there was no
party and that no copied rules were
broken that is what i've been repeatedly
assured
now the people who gave him those
assurances
led to him inadvertently misleading the
house
so have those people faced any
disciplinary proceedings
mr speaker first of all he needs to
to i'm afraid to await the conclusions
of the police inquiry uh because uh he
i'm afraid that uh he the the premise of
his question may not or may or may not
be uh substantiated but what i can tell
the house is yes as i've said before
there's certainly there certainly uh
will be changes in the way we do things
and changes in number 10.
duncan baker
speaker
north northwest consistently had some of
the lowest levels of infection in the
country
we followed
the rules
so many of my constituents have been
incensed the damage that this is doing
to the government is enormous it is
about integrity
and trust
can i ask again because people want to
know
how can the prime minister now
satisfy my constituents and assure me
that full accountability and
transparency on the findings of the
final grey report will swiftly
follow
yeah
well
mr speaker
i will do
whatever i can to ensure that this house
has as much clarity as possible there
are legal issues uh that that we face uh
mr speaker about some of the some of the
testimony that has been uh that has been
given uh but in the meantime uh what i i
think uh sue gray wants uh us to do is
to wait for the conclusion of the of the
investigation of the inquiry and to see
where that goes and to support the
police in their work
thank you uh mr speaker does the prime
minister
need somebody else to tell him whether
he was there or he is there now
i i refer the honourable answer i've
already given
mr speaker we all recognize that number
10 downing street is an unusual amalgam
of workplace office space and private
home what steps will the prime minister
take
um to ensure that the lines between each
of them are made clearer in the future
uh mr speaker that's
you will see that there are a
reference to that a very problem in sue
gray's uh report and we're going to take
steps and mr speaker to clarify things
and to make sure uh there are there is
greater transparency in the lines of of
command
stephen james
thank you mr speaker does the prime
minister recognize that repeatedly
making statements including from that
dispatch box which turn out subsequently
to be untrue
is a serious problem or does he not
recognize that
mr speaker i really think he's
pre-judging things and he should wait
for the conclusion of the of the
inquiries
paul holmes thank you mr speaker uh i
welcome the fact that my writing
boyfriend has come to this house as a
first step in responding to this report
he's also rightly outlined that the
relationship between number 10 and this
house needs to improve so will he
reassure me that he'll continue to come
to this house to update us on the
implementation of the recommendations in
sue grey's report and how that will
happen
yeah mr speaker i i will of course i'm
only too happy to uh assure the house
that we intend to
make changes starting from now and uh i
will keep the house updated
paula barker thank you mr speaker
when there's a failure of leadership
and an inappropriate culture in an
organisation the person at the top
should go
this outrageous debacle hasn't happened
in spite of the prime minister this has
happened because of the prime minister
will the prime minister now do the right
thing and resign
mr speaker the answer is no because i'm
going to wait for the conclusions of the
the conclusions of the inquiry uh before
before
all any of the assertions that she's
made can be established
mr speaker i
thank the prime minister for his
statement particularly the
acknowledgment of the enormous
sacrifice that so many british people
went through and as somebody who was
unable to say goodbye to my grandparents
this time
last year can i welcome his sincere
apology
but as we
are laughing as we wait
as we wait for the metropolitan police
findings can my right on my friend give
me a categoric assurance that it will be
full speed ahead on fixing the northern
ireland protocol standing up for our
friends in ukraine and fixing the cost
of living crisis
uh yes mr speaker that is exactly what
this government is going to do and
normal will be distracted for one minute
when david
i'm thinking thank you mr speaker in the
general findings to secure
sue gray's report there's a reference to
the failure of leadership and judgment
by number 10.
does the prime minister accept that sue
gray was largely referring to him
mr speaker i really think that he should
uh recite the whole report uh but i have
told him that i accept the findings uh
i've set the findings uh that sue gray
has given in full and we are acting on
them today
thank you speaker i um i welcome my
right honourable friend's apology he's
taken responsibility he's apologized and
it's right that he should do so
can i write an order from the prime
minister confirmed that tackling the
small boats crisis will remain top
of the new office of the prime minister
because that's what the country wants to
see he wants to see this prime minister
getting on with the jobs
yes that's right mr speaker and that's
why we brought forward the nationalities
and borders bill which i'm delighted to
say that she
supports that this government is getting
through which that party voted against
stephen
thank you the frequency of some of the
answers today and they don't answer to
other questions don't suggest the prime
minister is generally that sorry
does he recognize the long-term damage
he risks doing to historic norms of
democracy is it right that they are
sacrificing the interests of one man who
refused to do what the country knows
needs to happen and can he point to one
single example where he personally has
improved standards in public life
how about mr speaker
deciding to
honor the wishes of the people
and deliver brexit in spite of their
attempts mr speaker to subvert democracy
rob roberts
mr speaker delivery is key the prime
minister
delivers
he delivered on brexit
he delivered with furlough and with the
self-employed
scheme
that ensured businesses were able to
survive they can shout it down because
they don't like it mr speaker that's
fine
he delivered with one of the best
vaccination programs in the world
he delivered a country that is coming
out of a pandemic and an economy that is
thriving
with people who sadly lost their jobs in
the last two years having more vacancies
than ever to choose from
but nobody talks about those things mr
speaker
because all sides of those things
i think the pricer may have just got a
grip of what you've had to say prime
minister
uh well mr speaker we're going to
deliver on the people's priorities and
we're going to deliver and keep
delivering for wales
florence session though mate
thank you mr speaker mr speaker one of
the hardest things i had to do as an mp
is speak to the family of
ishmael mohammed abdulli
he was 13 years old when he died on the
30th of march he was one of the youngest
people to lose his life to covert
i will admit mr speaker when i spoke to
his mother i broke down on that call
ishmael's family like so many other
constituents up and down in vauxhall
followed the rule
many of them were scared to go out many
of them had to bury their loved ones
without being there
many of them walked past the covered
memorial wall in my constituency with
that heart showing their loss
does the prime minister now understand
and does he not feel ashamed that his
actions
have brought distribute to the office
that he holds
mr speaker of course i
uh
share the
honorable ladies grief for ishmael uh i
sympathize with
ishmael's family and
i understand the pain and loss of the
everybody's experience throughout this
country
but uh mr speaker all i can say is that
i will continue to do my best to fight
kobe as i have done throughout this
pandemic and and to deliver for the
british people and i can't say more than
that welcome
thank you mr speaker mr speaker running
an office and
having the required management expertise
of
running literally dozens and dozens of
offices with hundreds and hundreds of
people within
is one thing
running the country and getting the big
decisions right are quite another
so can i welcome the prime minister's
commitment
to have a look at what is happening at
number 10 and those management
structures so that we can deliver on the
promises and the brexit promises we gave
the people of this country
i i thank him very much and that's why
we're taking up the findings of the uh
the supreme report we want to make sure
that number 10 uh works better that the
whole of the government works better
it's been focused very much on uh on
covid uh but we now need to deliver
exclusively on the on the great
priorities of the people and abaldon
here
last summer my team and i said goodbye
to our colleague through the window of
her hospice as she died of cancer we
didn't get to hug her
and we were just like many millions of
people across the uk
we followed the rules while he and his
colleagues didn't and it makes me sick
to my stomach that we are not going to
get the findings of this report because
the police were so late to the party the
same met police who were happy to arrest
women who were protesting the murder
and it makes me sick to my stomach that
he does not understand the anger and
fury and upset of millions of people
across the uk because sometimes mr
speaker an apology won't cut it it's
time for action it's time for a clear
out it's time for him to resign
mr speaker i i again i i sympathize very
much with the experience of uh her
constituents
and all the pain that people have gone
through throughout this pandemic uh i
must say to her though that she is
prejudging uh the issue that the issue
in question today i don't think that's
the right thing to do i have a great
deal of respect for the police and i
think they should be allowed to get on
with their job paul hall
thank you mr speaker um
i think we've got to remember that we're
all talking about the breaking of the
rules
and the rules
clearly are under question here as to
what's happened but the rules themselves
that were put out by this government
have got this country to where it is and
we've got to remember that those rules
did the right thing
so yes there's got to be consequences in
number 10 for any rules that have been
broken but please remember the right
thing was done by the instigation of the
rules in the first place and i have to
say
when i'm talking to my constituents out
there they're saying yes we need to ask
the question about what's happened there
but can we stop being that as the only
soul subject and
can the opposition talk about something
else as well please do we need to move
on and level up this country
i i thank my honourable friend very much
and i think i think he's right the the
rules are important and it was very it
was it was it was amazing and remains
amazing uh to see the way people pulled
together throughout the the pandemic and
i i thank people very much uh but what
we need to do if we possibly can uh mr
speaker if the if the opposition would
uh well i think would would agree uh we
now need to focus on the issues that
matter above all to the british people
fixing the cost of living rebuilding our
economy clearing the kobe backlogs
that's what this government is doing
very sherman mr speaker i have known the
prime minister a long time um and we've
always got on quite well
he's not a wicked man
but he's a man that for years in every
job has got by flying on the seat of his
pants
he has a chaotic management style
and that is a question of character
and can i ask him really to look in the
mirror as he said this morning and say
am i the man at this challenging time
for our country overall at home in every
sense has he the character
to carry on and do that job problem
yes mr speaker because quite frankly
i think it was absolutely indispensable
that we had a strong
number 10 uh that was able to take us
out of the eu in spite of all the
efforts of the party opposite uh to
block it and not only that mr speaker a
booster and a vaccine campaign that were
led by number 10 that have made a
dramatic difference not just to the
health of this country but to the
economic fortunes of this country and
whatever he says about me and my
leadership that is what we have
delivered in the last year alone
scott benson you mr speaker when
knocking in dolls in blackpool at the
weekend i spoke to julie who said this
this prime minister has had the most
difficult job in living history he's
been dealing with a pandemic in which he
nearly died he's been dealing with the
media who haven't forgiven him for
delivering brexit
and yet
let's
he's been dealing with the media who
haven't forgiven him yet for dealing
with brexit and he hasn't had a chance
to crack on and deliver yet for british
people on their priorities
report today has come out the prime
minister has apologized let's allow him
to get on and deal awful
what you want to him sir
mr speaker i i want to say how
passionately vehemently and emphatically
i agree uh with the remarks which i
couldn't quite hear
of my of my honorable friend he is
completely right mr speaker and i think
that is the priority of the british
people that's the priority of the
government
thank you mr speaker mr speaker as
limited as the grey report uh was uh we
know that the the findings are still
incredibly damning
multiple
issues around uh failures of leadership
and judgment now given that the nolan
principles and standards of public life
describe
the centrality of integrity honesty and
leadership how can the prime minister
continue
i really think that she needs to read
the report carefully mr speaker
and
and and i'm afraid that the conclusions
that she's drawing are not ones that i
support but what we are doing mr speaker
is is following sue gray's advice and we
are changing the way number 10 runs and
we are going to uh to do things
differently mr speaker but i i can't
agree uh with what she says
catherine fletcher
mr speaker
on saturday i was out about enjoying ice
cream in lancashire which i know you and
your family do in some of the finest ice
cream parlors in the north of england
and they said to me
he's a wally
but a hundred thousand russians have
just turned up well and what the bloody
hell are we doing talking about cake
does the prime minister agree with that
statement
[Music]
i thank her very much uh i thank her
very much and i think that what the
country what the country needs and what
the west needs sorry can i just say if
you don't want to go in the question i'm
happy to pull stumps now but if you are
going to have questions i'm going to
hear the answers as well as the
questions prime minister
standing up you're going to sit down for
a bit
what the country needs now mr speaker is
a uk government
working with our friends and partners to
stand up to vladimir putin and to make
sure that we have a strong package of
sanctions and that's what we're doing
thank you mr speaker
the prime minister sets the culture at
number 10.
why does he think that staff members
there
felt unable to raise their concerns
about the bad behaviors reported in
today
oh
uh mr speaker that is one of the
recommendations of the uh the sugray
inquiry that we are going to take up to
make sure that nobody uh should feel
that uh in number 10 and that's why
we're going to review the code uh to
ensure that nobody feels that they have
uh any inhibition on coming forward with
any complaint that they may have uracil
mr speaker the prime minister and his
allies are trying to distract and
deflect from the truth but here are the
indisputable facts the prime minister
attended downing street parties he told
this house and the people that we
represent that he attended no parties
and in fact that there were no parties
the rules were clearly broken the
ministerial code has been violated so
when will he stop
stop insulting the intelligence of the
british people and do the right thing
and resign
mr speaker i i really think she's gonna
let the metropolitan police get on and
do their job
[Music]
mr speaker does the prime minister not
recognize that the public are rapidly
losing faith in the institutions that
they must be able to trust if your
democracy is to survive
because it appears that there is no
individual no organization no group or
no force whose reputation won't be
sacrificed on the altar of saving this
prime minister so can i ask the prime
minister does he consider the erosion of
public trust in the foundations of our
democracy a price worth paying to ensure
his personal survival
i mean speaker i believe that the
foundations of amongst the foundations
of our democracy our due process in the
rule of law and allowing the police to
get on with their job and that's what
we're going to do luke pollard
thank you mr speaker part four of sue
grey's report says that there is a
culture of excessive consumption of
alcohol which is not appropriate is
there also a culture of excessive drug
taking in downward streets
prime minister uh mr speaker any drug
taking would be excessive and perhaps he
should direct that question to the
labour front bench
mr speaker mr speaker
mr speaker
we've heard a lot about pre-judging
things today we only have to look at
paragraph three
of the general findings which talks
about fails of leadership judgement in
different parts of number ten
at the cabinet office and it says some
events should never have been allowed to
take place another event should not have
been allowed to develop as it did other
than that's prejudging anything it's
pretty clear it's only one person in
charge of number 10 in totality that's
the prime minister so let me just remind
the prime minister why this matters
about this real break in the way number
10 behave that'd be quote a constituent
one of a number of emails i have
constituents who lost loved ones
she said to me we received a call at 11
15 pm on the 29th of may 2020 saying mum
was deteriorating both my sister and i
drove to the home and spent the night
sat on a chair outside her bedroom
window watching her die
all i could do was sob and shout to her
and tell her that i loved her i couldn't
even hold her hand that's why you should
go prime minister
mr speaker i totally understand uh the
feelings of his uh his constituents and
uh i accept that uh things could have
been done better in uh in number ten as
i've told the house before but uh
really i i must ask him to uh study what
uh sue gray has said and and and and we
are acting on all her recommendations
thank you mr speaker can the prime
minister explain how changing the civil
service hierarchy will prevent him from
breaching the covet regulations as he
has admitted in this house
when will he take responsibility for his
own actions stop hiding behind other
people
my constituents don't want another
government department they want him to
resign
prime minister
mr speaker uh she's wrong in what she
said and i directed what i've said
earlier
thank you very much mr speaker it's been
further revealed that in april 2021 as
the prime minister partied he also
swiftly rejected the idea of bereavement
bubbles for those who've lost loved ones
suffered miscarriages stillbirths or a
child neonatal death
far from getting it he's deflected
laughed and smirked his way through this
statement he's a disingenuous man isn't
he
[Music]
prime minister
uh mr speaker i know uh this has been uh
a harrowing and tragic experience with
the entire country uh we've done our
best to uh to deal with it and uh i i as
for what she says about what's been
going on in number 10
i ask her to look at the report but also
to wait for the uh the police inquiry
owen johnson
thank you mr speaker now this afternoon
we've heard the distraction the
deflection there's confusion and we
can't even get the answers to the most
simplest of questions about whether we
can actually get the full report
published when it's available so mr
speaker could ask the prime minister is
it the case now that we're looking at a
situation of hobble hubble quite quick
mr speaker i i
nothing would uh give me greater
pleasure than to publish everything that
we currently have but the fact is mr
speaker that with our illegal
impediments and we have to wait until uh
the police inquiry is concluded so
william cash thank you mr speaker um i i
accept entirely what the prime minister
has just said it is absolutely essential
that we wait
it's absolutely essential that we wait
until we hear the next stage in this
these proceedings in relation to any
future investigations i'd also like to
draw attention to the historic
achievements of this prime minister
in the nation too
not only delivering brexit but in
relation to delivering the vaccine roll
out and in relation to his dealings with
mr putin and i believe that everybody
should take that most firmly into
account
i thank you very much and i think he's
completely right
and he might have added by the way that
we have the fastest economic growth in
the g7 uh mr speaker thanks to the steps
this government uh has been taking
care of insurance thank you mr speaker
we've established that there were
parties we are just really arguing about
who is responsible and as the honourable
member of thorax said earlier that's a
minister so if it's not him is it the
member for surrey heath or north east
cambridgeshire who should be facing the
sack
prime minister
i
remind the honorable lady what sue gray
says in her uh paragraph well no such
conclusion can be drawn uh so far mr
speaker she must wait uh she must wait
for uh the conclusion of the inquiry
mr speaker the prime minister announced
at the weekend that he would be calling
president putin to urge de-escalation of
the situation in ukraine
the mirror have just reported uh that
today the call has been cancelled
because he's been dealing with the sue
grey report so can the prime minister
confirm that on a matter of such grave
importance that this report is correct
and that will be speaking to vladimir
putin as soon as he leaves the chamber
prime minister mr speaker i'll be
speaking to president putin as soon as i
can
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
there i have read the report in full and
i think the most striking sentence
was the one
that there were failures of leadership
and judgment in different parts of
number 10 and the cabinet office at
different times
my constituents have been writing to me
whilst the prime minister has been
speaking
say that he should resign but they also
want to know the full facts
once the met has concluded
why could he not then
publish the full unredacted report prime
minister
mr speaker we have to see uh where the
police get to have to see the conclusion
of their inquiry we'll have to see what
the legal position is then mr speaker
mohammed jason
thank you very much mr speaker
why the students are deeply troubled and
angry by the frequent scandals engulfing
the prime minister's administration
because it's not just the party gate and
ongoing cover-up
but but all the other things
the perogan of parliament the treatment
of the queen the three point five
billion a chronicle with contracts
the writing of 4.3 billion kobe loan
fraud
and the russia report to name but a few
suspects sussex university researchers
have warned
that boris jones's administration is
more corrupt than any other
administration since second world war
does the prime minister knows this
doesn't he
is completely ridiculous he mentions uh
he mentions what we did uh for instance
to get brexit done which was absolutely
crucial to restore public trust in
democracy
richard holden thank you very much mr
speaker like me many of my constituents
have been appalled by the reports of
what's been happening in number 10 and
will welcome the fact that my rightful
friend has come to the house today and
has apologized in a first step to
responding to this will he assure me
that he will continue to keep the house
updated on the implementation the
measures he's taking in the report and
also will he ensure that there's full
cooperation from the whole of the number
10 team to the enquiries from the met so
they conclude as swiftly as possible
prime minister
uh yes mr speaker of course i will keep
the house updated and of course uh
everybody now in number 10 will
cooperate uh to the full uh with the men
thank you speaker this is surely now
a new low a prime minister of our
country forced to come here to the
mother of parliament and plead the fifth
in a criminal investigation because he
knows if the truth is told it will
incriminate himself
so let me just ask the prime minister a
simple question if he cannot get his
facts straight about whether or not he
was at a party in his own flat how will
anyone in this house ever believe a word
he says again and how will our partners
around the world ever put their trust in
him
mr speaker i'm not going to uh dignify
that question with an answer except to
say uh except to say that he's got to
wait everything he said is completely
prejudicial
hello
mr speaker i thought people in
lancashire were supposed to be straight
speaking because i i can assure sure
people that my constituents are calling
the prime minister a lot more than a
wally once i can't repeat reality is
half the staff invited to bring your own
booze party didn't turn up because he
knew it was wrong but yeah the prime
minister said he thought it was a work
event and within the
rules his lack of leadership and
judgment is also shown by the elected
bodies pile high comment about a second
lockdown the one thing that leader
scottish torres has said that it's true
is this prime minister is not fit for
office now given he'll do anything to
save his own skin does that mean the
leader of scottish stories is going to
get banned as well
prime minister
uh
mr speaker i direct him to i've said
earlier on
mick whitley
i think you know no one said in this
house
this afternoon
155 000 people died i've covered that's
why we introduced the rules
but this is simply not the comprehensive
report that the british republic were
promised for so long but at least it's
clear in its findings that there were
serious failures and i quote to observe
not just the high standards expected of
those working at the house of
governments but also of the standards
expected of the entire business
population at the heist of the pandemic
does the prime minister accept
responsibility for his failure to live
up to the standards which the vegetables
would respect its uphold
mr speaker i i've definitely said i take
responsibility for everything that
happened in number 10 and the government
did throughout the pandemic
harry gardner
the great report
is clear that there should be no
excessive consumption of alcohol in a
workplace
can the prime minister therefore assure
the house that his own consumption of
alcohol was not excessive and in
particular that his judgment was at no
time so clouded that he was in danger of
telling the truth
prime minister uh
mr speaker i i couldn't quite hear the
end of the uh roman general's question
uh but the answer is no if you think i
was i i drunk too much no
coach norris thank you mr deputy speaker
the prime minister wants my constituents
to suspend their disbelief and wait for
the met police to report
in which case will at least give them
clarity that should the metropolitan
police issue him with a fixed penalty
notice for participation at his party he
will resign
he really needs to wait and see what the
what the met uh decide
andrew
thank you we've had
excessive water boundary bluster and
bravado from the prime minister i
suggest to him politely that we need a
lot more humility from him given that
whilst the grey report might be paper
thin
it's very clear in the serious failings
at number 10
fish rots from its head can i suggest to
the prime minister it's not a new prime
minister's office we need it's a new
prime minister
well i i i hear him and i simply repeat
what i've said earlier on uh i'm
grateful to sue gray we're taking action
uh following her report but he needs to
wait for the conclusion of the inquiry
patricia gibson thank you mr deputy
speaker sue gray has made it clear
that this is not a report but it's an
update on the investigation into covered
breaches and downing street
indeed
in her update ms gray says she is
extremely limited in what she can say
and quote it is not possible at present
to provide a meaningful report
if it is the case that there's nothing
to see here move on as the prime
minister today is desperately trying to
convince us why has he repeatedly
refused to commit to publish the full
report even after the police
investigation has completed and what
does it say about the benches opposite
those populating them
if they still genuinely think that he is
the best amongst them to be prime
minister
[Music]
that's not what i've said
neil coyle
thank you mr debbie speaker the prime
minister told parliament and told the
british people that there were no
parties we now know he attended several
including one at which he was ambushed
with cake in his most pathetic excuse
yet given his previous statements which
we know to be patently false how does he
explain
why this report says at least 12 parties
in his home a warrant police
investigation
speaker he's proved several times in
that question that he hasn't got the
faintest idea what he's talking about
and he should wait for the outcome of
the inquiry
rupert
mr speaker the prime minister and his
apologies up to now had explained these
things away as one-offs you know a work
do
uh ambushed by a cake all those kind of
things but this report makes clear that
it was a repeated pattern of behavior
the booze-ups after work that nobody
else was having all our constituents who
followed the rules
so can i ask him as well it also says
that there was
there's an investigation of a downing
street party on the 13th of november
2020. why did he tell my honourable
friend for hornsey and woodgreen on the
8th of december that no such gathering
took place and subsequently he's told my
right honourable friend our leader that
anyone who from that dispatch box tells
mr truth
should resign
is he a man of his words
this is because she needs to to look at
what i said and she's look at the
outcome she needs to look at the outcome
of the inquiry
christine jardine
thank you very much mr deputy speaker um
the prime minister said in a statement
earlier
that he understands the anger
of people in this country but does he
also understand
that while they've been watching this
for many people in this country their
greatest fears about how this would be
handled been realized they've seen an
apology yes but obfuscation delay
tinkering rather than an acceptance of
responsibility
the prime minister says he wants to go
on and deal with the important issues
facing this country perhaps the only way
we will be able to do that
is for the prime minister to accept that
he has become an obstacle to it and
resign
no mr speaker we're going to get on with
the job
jeff smith
thank you mr deputy speaker the prime
minister was wrong in something he said
earlier the sugray update can be both
damning and incomplete
and most of us can only guess how much
more damning the full report is going to
be and his colleagues should worry about
that but i think he knows how bad it's
going to be because he knows what's
going on
so isn't that the real reason why i
won't commit to publishing the report in
full when the police have completed
their investigation
prime minister no mr speaker he's
totally prejudging the whole thing he
needs to contain himself no he needs to
contain himself and wait for the police
to complete their inquiries
drew hendry
thank you mr deputy speaker the sue grey
update
is not the report that this house
deserves it is not the transparency that
the public were expecting but it does
make it very clear that were there were
failures of leadership at number 10. the
prime minister is the leader at number
10. so will he now pack his suitcase or
will he leave it to his officials to
carry his cans
mr speaker he just needs to to look at
the uh report again and he needs to wait
for the conclusions of the inquiry
matt weston
thank you mr deputy speaker
look her in the eyes and tell her you
never
bend the rules
a lot of us remember that campaign cost
tens of millions of taxpayers
money
on the 13th of november in 2020 he bent
the rules didn't he
mr speaker i refer him to what i've said
earlier on in this house
and uh frankly mr speaker he needs to
wait until the conclusion of the police
inquiry
even flynn
thank you mr deputy speaker this morning
the conservative party in scotland
issued a press release and it stated and
i quote the pandemic sees rise in
criminals getting away with crimes
were they talking about the prime
minister
let's start mr speaker what we're
actually doing is cutting crime uh by
fourteen percent putting uh twenty
thousand more police twenty thousand
more police on the streets
roshner
alley thank you mr deputy speaker week
in week out throughout this pandemic
i like many of my colleagues had to deal
with constituents who couldn't see their
dying relatives or grieve with them and
some of us were directly affected when
we lost family members and loved ones
the prime minister's actions have made a
mockery of the british people's
sacrifices during the pandemic and now
he's the subject of a criminal
investigation it's a new low for our
country and our democracy and it makes a
mockery of our democracy to the rest of
the world if the prime minister takes
responsibility for everything that he's
that has happened as he has said
isn't it time that he put his party
this parliament and the country out of
their misery and steps down so that we
can move on and focus on the national
interest because at the moment it is not
possible because of the crisis that he
had and number 10 have created
prime minister oh no mr dick
we're just going to leave the commons
for a moment uh it's been a has to be
said a very difficult afternoon for
boris johnson some tricky moments uh
many calls for him to go from
uh all sides of the house and uh that is
continuing there but uh we're gonna
speak in a moment to our political
editor beth rigby but first of all we're
gonna take a a quick closer look at some
of the detail
in that report that was published
earlier today
it concludes that there were
failures of leadership and judgment by
different parts of number 10
and the cabinet office at different
times it adds that some events should
not have been allowed to take place
others should not have developed as they
did
it says that when the government was
asking citizens to accept far-reaching
restrictions on their lives some of the
behavior surrounding these gatherings
was difficult to justify some staff
wanted to raise concerns about behaviors
they witnessed at work but at times felt
unable to do so
the report adds that gatherings
represent a serious failure to observe
the high standards expected of those
working at the heart of government
lack of thought it says was given in
considering the appropriateness of
gatherings
and finally sue gray states that an
excessive consumption of alcohol is not
appropriate
in a professional
workplace
let's go live to our political editor
beth rigby in westminster so beth what
did you make of what you read in that
report and what you heard
afterwards in the comments
well mark the other point in that report
which the prime minister was leaning
heavily on but so were some of the
detractors in the commons there was when
sue gray said that it is not possible at
present
to provide a meaningful report now for
boris johnson that meant that he could
repeatedly say uh when uh members of his
own party and the opposition through
criticism at him wait for the police
inquiry to report you know the police
inquiry has been become the wait for sue
grey moment now it's wait for the police
inquiry
and the other point of that the
detractors were saying
was that you need to publish that report
in full this summary this 12-page
document does not give the british
public or indeed his mps who want to
take a view on his conduct as prime
minister it really doesn't give them the
substance that they need to form a
judgment about what went on in number 10
mark harper a very senior conservative
the former chief whip publicly asking
him will you publish that report in full
the prime minister simply kept denying
it and as he was
all sorry refusing to say that he would
uh put that report out in fallen as we
were on air listening to that statement
the met put out a statement saying that
they've had 500 pieces of paper over 500
bits of evidence
from the cabinet office and over 300
photographs
of those events the met now
investigating 12 different events on
eight different dates
in number 10 one of them the prime
minister explicitly asked at in the
commons refused again to answer
questions on it and that's the flat
party the alleged party in the flat on
november the 13th
when dominic cummings
says there was a party the night he left
he's obviously put that evidence into
seagray that now under investigation and
the prime minister directly asked about
his involvement in that again dodging
questions for now now hiding
against this defensive weight for the
met inquiry
yeah i mean all of which all that
evidence you've just been talking about
all of which suggests that it could be a
long police inquiry beth and then
there's the question of whether
we'll ever see
the full report that sue gray um
eventually comes up with
i i think that this is the most
important question now actually about
will we ever see the full report will
the truth ever really out now sue gray
has given a summary of events she
described it as an update not a full
report in good faith probably couldn't
put it as a full report simply because
there is no detail in it because she has
had to give only pass in reference to
some of the events now under
investigation by the met and the big
question now is will boris johnson
publish that report it will be his
decision it's not up to sue gray to
decide that she thinks it should come
out in full that is at the pm's behest
it's his in his gift uh his mps his own
mps demanding that it be published he
simply uh will not give a commitment in
the commons which i think
is very telling in itself but also mark
politically what was interesting in the
commons is the prime minister came out
quite bullish in tone he at the top
said that he was sorry he was sorry for
the things that number 10 didn't get
right he was sorry for the way it's all
been handled and then he said that he
would commit to try and improve the
leadership structure in the common uh in
number 10 sorry but what he's not doing
is committing to the full report which
is what many mps wanted and i think
theresa may the former prime minister
was the most critical really uh when she
stood up and said in the comments the
grey report shows number 10 was not
observing the regulations imposed by
them on the public either he didn't read
the rules the prime minister or he
didn't understand them or he didn't
think the rules applied to number 10
which was it in which care in which
point the prime minister replied i don't
think that's what the sue grey report
says but at least another nine of his
own mps stood up uh to publicly
criticize him over this or ask certainly
further questions and i think that's a
reflection of the political difficulty
he remains in and i think that maybe
when mps leave the chamber and reflect
on it perhaps he didn't get the tone uh
right today when he came out in a very
defiant way uh when sue grave has
sue grey has clearly uh talked about
failures of leadership talked about some
events should not have taken
place and talked about a culture of
drinking and
you know not good reporting lines in
number 10 he tried to bat it away but
those questions still remain
yeah and and um beth i mean just very
briefly he's talking to his mps tonight
isn't he's going to see his mps how will
he be received at that meeting
yeah he's going to go
brief mps at half past six but one
detractor pointed out to me today uh
that he is taking the whole
parliamentary party at this meeting it's
not just a meeting of the back benches
and if you have the whole parliamentary
party it means that you have a lot of
people there on the payroll i.e people
that you have given ministerial jobs to
people that would more naturally perhaps
support you
one mp who is not very happy with the
prime minister thinks that that is
because he wants to uh have support he
wants to have his allies by his side he
doesn't want to face angry backbenchers
without his own army of uh supportive
voices behind him look i think what is
clear from in the commons is whatever
the prime minister says that is a
divided party very senior former cabinet
minister standing up to criticize him
the former prime minister who very
rarely makes interventions publicly uh
criticizing him and yes there were cries
of support there
from mps but i for me uh the fact that a
number of mps went on record in the
commons
to quiz him and question him and
criticize him
is very significant it suggests that uh
however he might wish this has not gone
away it's not been put to bed and the
big question now will be will he publish
this report in full will we get to the
truth of what happened in number 10
during those lockdowns as i said there
are a dozen uh parties being
investigated by the met this is not a
one-off this is not a one-off mistake
this is a systematic issue of rule
breaking a ledgeral break-in in number
10 that the meton are investigating
okay well look we're hopefully going to
discuss more of this beth with the
former chief with mark harper in just a
moment but first let's just listen now
to uh boris johnson's apology at the
beginning of his statement uh this
afternoon and uh also to the response
from the labour leader sakir stama
firstly i want to say
sorry
and i'm sorry for the things we simply
didn't get right and also sorry for the
way that this matter has been handled
and it's no use
saying that this or that was within the
rules and it's no use saying that people
were working hard
[Applause]
this pandemic
was hard for everyone
we asked people across this country to
make the most extraordinary sacrifices
not to meet loved ones not to visit
relatives before they died and i
understand the anger that people feel
but mr speaker it isn't enough
to say sorry
this is a moment when let's look at
ourselves
in the mirror
and we must learn
and while the metropolitan police must
yet complete their investigation
and that means there are no details of
specific events in sue gray's report
i of course accept
sue grey's general findings in full
and above all her recommendation that we
must learn from these events and act now
with respect to the events under police
investigation she says and i quote
no conclusions should be drawn or
inferences made from this other than it
is now for the police to consider the
relevant material in relation to those
incidents but more broadly
she finds that there is significant
learning to be drawn from these events
which must be addressed immediately
across government
this does not need to wait for the
police investigations to be concluded
that is why we are making changes now
to the way downing street and the
cabinet office run
so that we can get on with the job the
job i was elected to do mr speaker and
the job that this government was elected
to do
the prime minister repeatedly assured
the house that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed
but we now know
that 12 cases have reached the threshold
for criminal investigation
which i remind the house
means that there is evidence of serious
and flagrant breaches of lockdown
including including the party on the
20th of may 2020 which we know the prime
minister attended and the party on the
13th of november 2020 in the prime
minister's flat
there can be no doubt that the prime
minister himself is now subject to
criminal investigation
[Applause]
the prime minister must keep his promise
to publish sue grey's report in full
when it is available
but it is already clear that the report
discloses the most damning conclusion
possible
over the last two years the british
public have been asked to make the most
heart-wrenching sacrifices
a collective trauma
endured by all
enjoyed by none
our national story about covert is one
of the people that stood up when they
were tested
but that will be forever tainted by the
behavior of this conservative prime
minister
and now he's finally fallen back on his
usual excuse
it's everybody's fault but his
they go
he stays
but prime minister the british public
aren't fools they never believed a word
of it
they think the prime minister should do
the decent thing and resign
[Music]
of course he won't
because he is a man without shame
cherishing and nurturing british
democracy is what it means to be
patriotic
there are members opposite who know that
and they know the prime minister is
incapable of it
the question they must now ask
themselves is what are they going to do
about it
it is only they that can end this pass
the eyes of the country are upon them
they will be judged by the decisions
they take now
[Music]
skirstama there well criticism came from
all corners of the commons the former
prime minister and conservative mp
teresa may questioned boris johnson's
understanding of the rules at the
current time the incident took place
what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it